it's been a heck of a week
rudy giuliani's apartment in office gets
raided by the doj or by the feds
seizing his electronic devices and that
is chilling to say the least
i know a lot of people were hoping
donald trump would arrest some corrupt
individuals well the left is getting
their wish because republicans don't
seem to ever do anything like this
and a lot of people probably thought it
would just never happen it would never
come to this but here we go
the bigger story now that's in many ways
shocking
is that we're learning the feds had a
secret plan if derek chauvin
was acquitted meaning they could not
convict him he committed no
he was cleared of all wrongdoing they
were going to file a criminal complaint
and arrest him at the courthouse
because he was uh found guilty on all
counts
they didn't need to do it need to do it
that's that's the way it's been framed
in the media does that mean need to do
it
why would you need to arrest a man who
was found not guilty
on all counts it's not about whether
he's guilty or not it's about
the mob just getting some kind of
symbolic retribution
against the police and that sacrifices
derek chauvin and
the remaining officers see now that he's
been found guilty
they're sending the case to a grand jury
who very well may say
no crime was committed and then it just
disappears this is shocking
justice in this country is gone and i
mean the system just keeps falling apart
joe biden's ratings are in he gave a
speech less than half
even cnn says that in their polling
donald trump did better in his first
speech than joe biden did even cnn is
saying that
granted cbs is saying 85 percent of
those who watched joe biden speak
were you know felt good or liked what he
had to say
85 percent except his ratings were
dramatically down from trump's speech
not particularly popular and now we got
another story out of seattle 200
officers have resigned
this is crazy man feels like the system
is on fire not to mention
kamala harris's failures of the border
so joining us today is the intrepid
drew hernandez how's it going man what's
going on tim thanks for having me just a
quick introduction
yeah well my name is drew hernandez for
those that don't know me i'm the host of
drew hernandez live on youtube you can
follow me on twitter drew h live uh yeah
i'm sure you've seen some of my viral
footage covering the uh
riots in 2020 and going on in 2021
now doing a lot of you're covering that
and the border and the border yeah a lot
at the border we're going to get into
that
tonight as well a lot of stuff that uh
this isn't
like before i talk about this tonight i
just want people to understand
when i talk about the border um this
isn't like some kind of like
conservative talking point type of thing
smearing
the left or smearing a smearing
democrats i
this is a serious issue um i i don't
care what your politics are you should
you should seriously get behind some of
the things that you may have never heard
tonight because obviously kamala harris
isn't doing anything about it so
absolutely we're gonna have to get into
that later in the show right on we got
ian well hello everyone ian crossland
here at ian crossland and
ian crossland.net if you'd like to
follow me there check it out
yeah and i'm over here in the corner
pushing buttons i'm sarah patch lids
this is freaky man yeah we we did a show
yesterday with jack and it was just like
it was not you know it went well beyond
raining on someone's parade it was what
do you say acid
acid rain and fire and brimstone people
screaming as their skin melts in front
of them it's just not raining a parade
man the parade's just engulfing in
flames and
wow these stories are freaky so before
we get started head over to teamcast.com
become a member
there's a big blue button in the top
right it says members only click that
button and you can sign up
then get access to this amazing members
only area you should check out some of
the conversations we've been having we
had a very serious conversation
with jack last night about what the
founding fathers would be expecting
today and it is a pretty brutal
conversation
because i think most people would assume
the founding fathers would have done
something very different
at this point in in in history had they
been around but uh we we do bring up
some
interesting points about the modern
state of warfare fifth generation fourth
generation etc
so uh go to the go to tempguest.com sign
up and don't forget to like share
subscribe
hit the notification bell and uh if
you're listening to this on itunes or
spotify or any other podcast platform
leave us a good review give us five
stars and as always share the story my
friends
let's get into one of the most shocking
stories
i've ever seen from the star tribune and
i love the framing on the story
feds plan to indict chauvin other three
ex-officers on civil rights charges
ex-cop would face federal charges in two
cases three others in the floyd case
they say leading up to the derek chovan
murder trial
justice department officials had spent
months gathering evidence but they were
worried that
this case if they went after shoving it
could disrupt the state's case
so they came up with a contingency plan
if you were found not guilty on all
counts
or the case ended in a mistrial they
would arrest him
at the courthouse according to sources
familiar with the planning discussions
that's that's an incredible statement
they go on to mention
under the contingency arrest plan the
minnesota u.s attorney's office would
have charged chauvin by
criminal complaint why didn't they
if their if derek chovin committed a
crime why
doesn't the state file a criminal
complaint
because this is not about whether he's
innocent or guilty they're going to say
a quicker alternative
for a federal charge that does not
require a grand jury
so they could arrest him immediately and
then
ask the grand jury for an indictment but
they wouldn't need one they literally
just said in the article they would not
require a grand jury
so uh why interesting say according to
sources who are not authorized to speak
publicly
this sounds to me like the doj is a
tool completely at this point of the
democrats going after giuliani
and this story should make your hair
make should make the hair on the back of
your neck stand up
there's no justice you combine this with
the story of all these mass resignations
of cops and
i don't blame them i applaud them
because they're they want retribution
these these are zealots who have reached
the highest level of government let me
just say one more thing before we break
out a bigger conversation
is what i was warning of a couple years
ago when i talked about the potential
for civil war
people like oh shut up the federal
government is strong and i'm like what
happens when the zealots
get into positions of power or those in
position
positions of power get converted to the
cult
and become this this rage machine what
happens when antifa finds its way into
the doj
this well if he's found not guilty
meaning he could not be convicted we'll
arrest him anyway
what makes it even crazier the judge
flat out said
it would be impossible i'm going to
paraphrase be a little hyperbolic but he
said
it's impossible for shove and have a
fair trial so screw it
the defense wanted the jury sequestered
he said no no we're not going to do that
the defense wanted a change of venue how
can we have a fair trial
in minneapolis where all these riots are
happening and the judge said there's
nowhere they can go
in the state where this won't happen
okay if there's no way to have a fair
trial
case dismissed because we are not just
locking random people up but
we've become a nation that started as it
is better that 10 guilty persons escaped
than one in
innocent suffer two it is better that
the innocent
suffer if it makes the cult feel good
or i guess prevents you know i i would
say maybe if it
prevents rioting but we know that
doesn't happen the riots still happen so
welcome to the to the brave new world i
kind of blame myself
at least that i didn't take it seriously
that this this mentality could permeate
into the government
until like 2017 or 2018 and i was like
oh oh
maybe it's too late by the time i
realized
even back then people were telling me oh
antifa fighting with proud boys is
nothing it's not gonna get to the doj
and besides
donald trump is president here we are
well i think we have to understand part
of their ideologies with black lives
matter and antifa they're
they are cultural marxists they are neo
anarchists and part of what they want to
do is they want to subvert
not only law enforcement that makes
sense to me because that's what they do
is they subvert law enforcement and
right now that includes the doj that
includes the fbi that includes
uh the da's like in portland you see
that they're dropping charges left and
right so
for me i think and i know you know this
tim but for people that are listening
it's like
what they want to do is invade every
single channel in our society including
law enforcement so it makes sense to me
that these things are beginning to
unfold in our country because if they
could decimate law enforcement who gets
hurt
the innocent get hurt but that's what
they want to do my personal opinion tim
i don't think they want to get rid of
police i don't think they want to
abolish the cops they want to usher in a
new regime
right they want themselves to be in
power that's what we're starting to see
that's why i was going to say they're
not anarchists
anarchists true anarchists are either
going to be like
i can buy that off you or would you like
to come to an agreement as to how we can
exchange
the value of our labor that's anarchy it
means without authority
the people who claim to be anarchists
they're not anarchists they don't know
what they're talking about these people
might say we want to abolish the police
but what happens when someone confronts
them on the street
what happens when these people are
filming there's a video 911 help call
the police
that's right they want the cops there's
a video where a guy in his own home
has all these black lives matter people
yelling and screaming at him so he
brandishes a shotgun he shouldn't have
brandished it
he could maybe like have it prepared but
he'd be pointed out the window should
have done that
but when the cops show up they'll clap
and cheer yay yay for the police
they want the cops to do their betting
and guess what they got it they won yeah
everything that they do is an attack on
law enforcement because when you
when you take a look at how things are
taking place and unfolding right
you look at the ohio shooting right
mckay bryant you look exactly what took
place you had
a white cop that saved the life of a
black person
while in the process taking another
psychotic black life because she was
lunging out another black person
uh at her throat with an it was two
women right she was yeah there was
another woman on the floor getting
kicked in the head by a black guy right
so it's like but here let me finish my
point my point is
black lives matter has branded the death
of black
people at the hands of cops regardless
of what the context is
so a lot of people don't understand this
tim they're like well why don't they
talk about black on black crime
fbi statistics under barack obama the
first
black president in united states history
was skyrocketing through the roof so is
that of
is that a product of white supremacy
none of it makes sense but why
why don't they talk about black on black
crime very simple
it doesn't fit the brand it doesn't
attack law enforcement
every time you talk to an activist and
black lives matter i see this on twitter
all the time
drew how could you be so stupid and
naive are you that dumb
black lives matter is not about black on
black crime
it's about police brutality i'm like
okay well then let's talk about the
facts and the statistics if that's what
you're claiming
they don't add up i literally had a
conversation tim with someone in
minneapolis right after the shelvin
verdict was announced i asked her are
you guys satisfied
what what what are your thoughts and
she's like we're never going to be
satisfied
black lives matter forever and she
literally said we're experiencing a
black
genocide okay a black genocide
in the context of police brutality where
are the numbers
they don't add up listen what people
need to understand tim is this
it's not about black lives it's about
decimating law enforcement with the
result
of destabilizing the united states of
america that their neo marxist that's
what they
thought i think the first part about law
enforcement's a little reductive because
i think the bigger picture is
every cultural institution yeah all of
it so cnn is currently undergoing an
internal
review about the mistreatment of women
or whatever you open up the doors you
let the wolves in what do you think is
going to happen
now they're getting eaten alive from the
inside it's probably going to rip them
apart the new york times had already
happened we saw that with barry with
barry weiss she's
she left because the wokeness permeates
and i i can't remember where this quote
was so correct me if i'm wrong people
listening or watching or watching
that something like an idea ideology
only needs around 10 percent
of the country in order to completely
change the government and the culture
because look we've got well
on a broader point so that was a general
idea but the broader point is when you
have the law
the 1964 civil rights act you can't
discriminate on the basis of these
things
okay well the laws in stone now they
exploit the law oh you discriminated me
and i accuse you because of race
what do you do well now you're being
sued and the government's going to be
like okay well it is illegal we'll take
this up most regular people find racism
abhorrent
so it becomes a very easy attack factor
to manipulate the system
and gain power and then it's really
interesting when you see these stories
about
how the woke try to take over
organizations by making all these insane
nonsensical claims you can't do anything
about because it's like oh it's white
supremacy
i'm not white yeah but it's the system
of white supremacy but this
test that we're you know the system we
implement is actually founded by a black
guy no no
no it goes even beyond that it's a black
white supremacist like no matter what
you say
right now they're calling tim scott a
black white supremacist because they
have to
they have to use that attack vector and
unfortunately the real problem is
regular people in this country don't
care anymore demoralization yep
the average person says i don't care
leave me alone
now that they're demoralized and they
don't want anything to do with anything
you'll get judges like cahill in the
choven verdict who's like
i could change venues but then they'll
burn my house down so screw it throw
them to the wolves
better for me the rest of the country
yeah we don't seem to care
and we're bowing down to the regime in
my opinion i think it's racist
that's a controversial thing to say it's
because these cultural marxists
they always have a villain right in
historical marxism
there's always a villain the people at
the top and there's always the victims
right now in 2021
they are making the minorities the
victims and who are the villains
white people that is all you're seeing
everywhere in disney and nickelodeon
everywhere you see tim every and i got
to say this because
before you move on that point that's not
true it is true why they're calling tim
scott a black white supremacist they're
attacking candace owens people like tim
scott
it's more about people who believe in
american values
they're using white as an attack as an
attack factor because the majority of
the country is white
but let me finish clearly when you get
latinos and asians and black people they
attack them in the exact same way
and it makes no sense let me finish my
point my point was this is why i said i
think it's racist
because no matter what you do no matter
what you say
they'll always blame it on white people
but the key factor is
we have to keep the victims where they
are
if you're a person of color i'm going to
use their terminology if you're hispanic
if you're black
if you're candace owens if you're tim
scott it doesn't matter
we'll call you a white supremacist
because the factor is
we have to keep you as a victim that's
why i say
this is racist as hell the racists are
on the left
because they always want to paint
someone like me as a damn victim
that i'm always down in the dumps and
joe biden stands up after the shelvin
trial verdict and tells the whole world
blacks and browns are living in fear of
going to the grocery store
blacks and browns are in fear going to
sleep at night and i'm sitting there
watching the tv
living a great life i am not a victim
tim i will never be a victim
racism is real i've experienced racism
in my own life my little sister
is a victim of a physical assault from
an ex-cop who is a white supremacist and
a racist so is my mother
okay i grew up with this stuff and i
gotta say this because i've experienced
it
but i'm not the type of woke tarted left
wookie that just sits there and says
well we gotta just smear all white
people because we will forever be
victims
that narrative is coming from an elitist
mentality that is telling us that we are
victims
and we will continue to be victims and
there's nothing we can do to get out of
it
listen even black lives matter right i
know this isn't it wasn't
done right she's a multi-millionaire who
the co-founder
right what's her name patrice patrice
coolers patrice coolers is a
multi-millionaire because she's a
grifter
she's branded the death of black people
so she's living the high life
why why does the mainstream media have
to continue to censor those stories
because they have to keep the narrative
that a black person is still a victim
there's two things one as we've seen
with cnn and new york times and other
outlets
they're effectively infiltrated by cult
members
who want to push the narrative for the
sake of pushing the narrative
but at the top you have the capitalistic
interest of
we make money when we push this
narrative
and if we tell them a counterpoint we
will
lose money i've experienced it firsthand
when i worked for
for fusion abc news univision they said
we side with the audience
so if you keep telling people there's
there's something that's true you keep
saying black lives matter
and then one day a story comes out
michaia bryant's got a knife
well you can't report that story it'll
piss off the audience you've cultivated
so they don't yeah they ignore it it
doesn't fit the brand exactly minorities
victims
black people can do nothing for
themselves latinos and hispanics could
do nothing for themselves to the point
of not being able to be educated enough
or funded enough to go get a to go get
an id to vote
but listen i'm not listen tim this is
what they say
i am in the mainstream media as a person
of color they say i'm too stupid to get
an id
that i'm too poor to get an id they tell
me that i'm scared to go to sleep at
night
because i fear cops are gonna knock down
my door and kill me in my sleep
that's not who i am and i got to be
extremely passionate and aggressive
against this
because listen i've never been someone
to say hey uh
i'm this hispanic conservative latino
guy follow me i was telling lydia this
in the car earlier on the way here
that's never been who i am but now i've
come to the point where i'm like if i
don't speak
up for myself these damn democrats and
radical leftists
will brand me they will brand me they
will speak
who i am they will tell me who i am they
will say who i
am they'll say that i'm a victim they'll
say i'm too poor
they'll say that i'm not smart enough
they will brand me and label me these
things and if i don't
say anything aggressively then that's
who i will become
in the eyes of millions of people thank
god i have the platform right now to say
these things
listen let's do let's do a poll how many
people in the chat
agree with me right now with what i'm
saying drop a one in the comment section
below
if you are sick of these damn
politicians branding who we are
let's use their labels as people of
color i'm not stupid tim
i'm not too poor i am successful i am
strong
i am godly i am someone that could
actually do something with my life
and right now i will never sit here and
say i speak for all people of color
no no i speak for myself but what i can
say is
there's a lot of people out there in the
country tim that are sick
of this victim mentality stuff because
that is not who we are as people not
enough
not enough of them i don't know so yeah
maybe maybe right now
uh you got this platform but the truth
is people who are watching this show are
most of them likely watching it because
they already agree with you and that's
the problem
so there's a lot of people who watch
this show and many shows like it
and they agree and disagree with me on
many things but it's a it's a good
conversation
but they know exactly what you're saying
that that's why they're here but how do
people
not see that that's racist as hell tim
because the symbol
and continue to continue to paint
minorities
as it's ridiculous the issue is exactly
that's my point
and your people don't realize that
they're being lied to when are people
gonna wake the hell up
this is a narrative that's causing you
to believe something
that is racist within itself how many
times are you gonna how many times i
don't care
they gotta care tim because i'm getting
sick of this happening to our
communities
they keep painting us with these
stereotypes it's coming from the left
listen to joe biden
he's literally the person that's
peddling these narratives kamala harris
blacks are too poor
uh uh brown people are scared to live in
this country they could do nothing for
themselves
that's not true i can do something for
myself
i'm an american i can do things people
are sick
of this garbage and i i just got to be
passionate tim because you know i think
i think people are sick of this stuff
dude and for me
all for watching i just because people
aren't speaking for me i disagree
i think you're mad about it i think i'm
mad about it i think ian is i think
lydia is
i think most people who come on this
show are mad about it
and then we've even had some people on
the show who just don't care
and they know people who are more likely
on the left and they're like yes so what
and then we get most americans who just
want to fit in
some who are too stupid some who are too
demoralized
and some who know exactly what's going
on but better to keep your head down
than get it chopped off oh they're
cowards
absolutely they're cowards these people
are cowards because listen let's talk
about
the border right now these people claim
to care about latinos
they care about hispanics they care
about us
these politicians i don't care your left
or right what's happening at the border
is crimes against humanity okay joe
biden called
he's on record running for president he
said we need to
immediately surge the border and in
context he was speaking
directly to central america this has
caused even he said
he said we need to immediately surge the
border on the debate stage speaking
directly to central americans that's not
fake news that's not out of context you
can find the clip right now that is
exactly what he said
that is who he is so now we have an
influx the worst numbers we've seen
dhs border patrol every single one that
i've interviewed they all say the same
exact thing the same exact thing these
are the worst numbers we've seen
in the past 20 years and joe biden
caused this the democrats want this
they're continuing to allow this to
happen the reason why kamala harris will
not go down to the border is because
they know that they want nothing but
votes
that's all they want all these central
americans are nothing going to be people
that are going to be legalized in order
to vote for generations to come for
people
to vote for the democrat party all we
are are political pawns they don't care
about latinos they don't care about
hispanics they only care about their own
political gain
that is who these people are and there
are even republicans
i know people aren't going to like me
saying this but republicans take this
narrative and they only use it as a
talking point
to score political points with latinos
that care about this stuff
i'm saying this stuff because this is
the reality of what's taking place
we literally the atrocities are insane
tim people coming from central america
because this president caused this
literally women being raped literally
kids being kidnapped
people that are dying being murdered by
the cartels before they even get to the
southern border and i'm supposed to
believe joe biden when they say they
care about latinos and hispanics
no you don't put people in that kind of
position in order for them to get
killed and raped and murdered and
kidnapped not to mention what's taking
place with the actual kids
at the border you have kids you have
three-year-old little babies being
chucked off the top of a 14-foot border
wall
you have little kids being deserted at
the southern border
to die by human smugglers with no food
no water nothing and i'm supposed to sit
here and believe that these politicians
care about me
and my communities no it's garbage they
never did they never did they never will
but the reason why i'm going to continue
to say this tim
i i know there's always going to be
people out there that have never even
thought about this stuff
there has to be someone out there that
needs to finally open their eyes and see
these people are only using us for
political gain they use the color of our
skin
to gain political points and then they
don't they don't listen to us
all they do is use us for votes people
are sick of it tim
they are sick of it i can assure you the
latino community
is getting fed up with this garbage
that's true because we see it on a daily
basis
these are the families that we're seeing
in florida a safe blue district
went republican and we saw the southern
counties
southern districts in texas which are
heavily latino and hispanic
switch from democrat to republican and
that's shocked a lot of the analyst
pollsters and everybody nobody saw that
coming
because they know they know people
aren't tell you what does that tell you
what does the left tell you latinos are
so uneducated they need so hell they
need
so much help they're to the stupid brown
people they need oh we need to coddle
them and
and put these training wheels on them
because they can't do anything for
themselves
oh my gosh the minorities are two no no
we can think for ourselves and that just
proves it
i can vote for myself i don't need to be
told who i need to vote for i can view
the world myself
i can analyze the world myself i'm smart
enough to view this
no it's not i'm speaking to a community
right now i can assure you
yes there are people out there the
message from the democrats
is not for you it's not for latinos it's
not for black people it's for
uppity white well-to-do liberals and
progressives
and they're being told by the democratic
party you're a superhero
the poor brown people need your help
they don't care about what you
think they're not saying these things to
convince you of anything
it's because you have a whole bunch of
ultra white suburban progressive
neighborhoods
that are super racist but they have
guilty consciences yes
so now now they can bask in the you know
who was it george w bush bush who said
the soft bigotry of low expectations
now it's the hard bigotry of no
expectations which is
they straight up think y'all uh i
shouldn't even say y'all
because depending on the time of day
they might say the same thing about
asians
they think oh the poor minorities but
then the moment you say anything to
counter them they say you're actually a
white supremacist yeah
they listen they don't want us
successful
because once we become successful we
don't fit their racist narrative anymore
okay this this is i'm living this right
now
like i've been saying people can tell
i'm not a victim i'm i'm successful i
know what i'm doing
but now because i don't fit the
narrative like you said
they'll call you a white supremacist i
was literally called the other day
a mexican white supremacist russian
asset
okay so that's like the new narrative
listen all of them all in one right
so it's like but they don't realize that
they're racists
because you guys claim that you want
minorities successful
you guys claim that you want us on the
same level as white people which is in
my opinion a racist
kind of like platform to begin with but
okay i'll give you that
but once i get there i get censored
i get called a race traitor i get called
a traitor
i get called stupid i get called like i
said a mexican white supremacist russian
ass so
it's interesting because these people
claim to care so much about minorities
but the moment a minority starts to get
on the next level and begins to speak
for himself or herself
they just get shot down they get told to
shut up so it's like you people don't
care
what i'm trying to say is that's racist
within itself because you are not
wanting minorities to progress
because once we do you destroy us
because if you don't have us down
you have nothing to cure your damn white
guilt or whatever your guilt is that you
have in your heart
people need jesus tim what's the so
what's the solution when
people already seek out information and
know these things and the people
and other people just don't want to like
i i have friends
who the moment you raised your voice
would tell you to screw up they'd walk
away
yeah they'd say i i don't care he's a
white supremacist because honestly bro
if you can't get behind but they don't
care you don't understand no you
just we have to stop pretending like the
the people in the left who are marching
with their fists up
actually care about any of this most of
them say outright they are racists on
tick tock they make videos
where they say it so when you go to them
and say this is racist they go
we know shut your mouth and get on my
face
and you're not convincing the racist of
doing anything because they're racist
i would bet that for every person that's
like i can't take it it's too much
10 people will be like whoa because what
you were saying was enlightening i
already knew that stuff but it was like
wiring my brain
it is racist to say that black people
have it rough
that's that you you're subjugating them
by well that's that's an
oversimplification
to say that they're on a a weaker level
or unable yeah
is racist especially for little kids
that hear that and they're like i'm
you're three and four and you believe it
implicitly
oh so i am a victim and i am going to
have a hard life
then you just live a hard life and so
seek out your soul
think about what the average person
who's been told this
will do let's say you have two people
one person is told when they're growing
up
no matter what happens to you
it's your fault no matter what take
responsibility for literally everything
the other person is told no matter what
happens it's white supremacy
it's never your fault what do you think
happens when that first person
encounters a problem
so i'll give you an example i was told
this when i was growing up
i was late for school i got a tardy slip
or something why was i late there was a
train
and i said it's not my fault there was a
train you know my dad said
you know the train tracks are there you
know
the trains go there why didn't you plan
ahead
you should have taken responsibility for
the fact that the train tracks are
already there
you didn't think did you and i was like
i didn't think there's gonna be a train
well now you know don't you so take
responsibility for the fact that you did
not prepare for the train
something you knew and imagine the other
kid showing up
it's not fair because the train came and
it's because the system
of this country is white supremacist so
they decided that they could build train
tracks through low-income neighborhoods
and that means that poor people are
stuck waiting for trains now they're not
going to do anything
to solve their own problems when people
are told it's not your fault and there's
nothing you can do about it
then they don't do anything about it
when other people are told
maybe it's not your fault but you need
to figure out how to solve the problem
they will maybe the answer was i drive
to
a mile down until i find the bridge and
then you know go under or over or
whatever
maybe there's a solution to the problem
maybe you'll leave 10 minutes early
maybe you'll leave 20 minutes early
but if it's always racism there's no
solution
none literally there can be none because
right now this country is majority white
it will be for a long time so they've
created a problem with no solution
so long as they keep telling people this
people will just keep sitting there
sitting in it
but the the bigger point i suppose is
that the woke leftists
even people i know even people in my in
my family my extended family
i see these photos of them marching with
their fists up and i'm like they don't
know what that fist means they don't
know the origin of it
they don't care either they are vapid
lazy entitled and they are only out
marching because
we're in with the crowd hey this is what
my friends are doing
you you could ask them any question
about police brutality gun violence they
won't be able to answer it
and then you know what happens
afterwards i tell you this
because i've been to these protests go
to one of these protests and see one of
these average people marching
and then once the march is winding down
go up to any one of these people and say
now we're going to go to a a an office
for a charity that deals with actually
solving these problems
and you know they'll say no they won't
do it why
i used to work for non-profits
fundraising and recruit
and trying to find members for
organizations i used to be in these
protests and i can assure you
one of the most annoying things to me
was how i realized most of these people
are just virtue signaling marching down
the street
to post their stupid photo on facebook
so they can pretend to be a good person
while they're over consuming and burning
the plant to the ground while
complaining that you're doing that
they're not doing anything that's most
people and you know what
these are the same people that go and
post videos of themselves voting
and i i i had friends who were like
here's my ballot i voted for biden watch
me go vote and they would like put in
the mailbox and i'm like
you're a fan of biden huh quick name his
policies
and they'd be like i was like that's a
joke right name all of biden's policies
how about the one where he created that
crime bill they have no idea
and they say well it's not about biden
but you know donald trump is pretty bad
okay why
why is he bad no no frail i got some
opinions on why he's bad can you tell me
yours
well he lies all the time what do you
lie about you know like
dude come on you know he lies what do
you lie about
come on come on are you just repeating
what you heard on the tv you saw a post
on facebook you have no idea what you're
talking about
stop wasting my time and so now we have
a whole bunch of people
who don't care about civics who don't
care about community who don't care
about this country
and it's everything's just crumbling
down around them and the main problem is
we as a country have already been
demoralized
there is no sense of country there is no
sense of community no one is fighting
for one another they're fighting for
money
and the money ain't there they ain't
gonna do it that's it
some people are i think that but it when
it comes to demoralization it wouldn't
be like a one or a zero there's a
sliding scale like how demoralized how
moralized are you right now
65 percent how how moralized were you
yesterday
64 i don't know i think that's part of
why what we do is important having these
conversations and showing people that
they're not alone
i think that's pivotal for keeping up
morale that's essential for this battle
that we're going into i do think that
demoralization is deep
i don't personally see a direct way out
but i do know that one of the best ways
to get there is by having this kind of
conversation
let's talk about the extreme levels
demoralization ladies and gentlemen from
kiro 7 seattle over 200 seattle police
officers quit amid national protests
in bravo bravo to each and every one of
these officers who have
quit the department and won't be party
to the corrupt system anymore
and i know we're talking about
demoralization the system falling apart
but at a certain point you need to stop
propping up the broken system
part of the demoralization exists
because these people who march to the
street with their fists in the air have
never had to deal with any real problems
because they just call the police please
do it for them
they don't actually know or care about
the police most these people
in these big cities never interact with
police but they hate them
it's remarkable you ever actually talk
to one of these guys about their job
no but i hate them great well over in
seattle they say
spd said more than 200 officers have
left their jobs since last year
the departing officers have cited what
they call as anti-police climate in
seattle
the city council police policies and
disagreements with police department
leadership police chief adrian diaz said
tuesday the department is in what he
called a staffing crisis
it's funny it says story uh originally
by the ap
but uh not too far away from here i
think it's hagerstown
they're in a a uh police shortage as
well crisis
we also have louisville in serious
crisis
everywhere across the country serious
crisis but you know what i'm glad the
cops are leaving
these people who live in these cities
who march around and just don't
care at all they're virtue signaling
every day
the reason so so let me clarify my
position for those that may not have
heard it because many of you probably
have but just very quickly
before the election it was very much
guys we need cops
we can have reform we can we can we can
get better training and better
specialties
but we need a police department and i
understand if there are things we can
change we should
i don't like it when cops enforce
unconstitutional laws
but i've lived in big cities i know what
happens when you don't have cops and you
have no one to call and
i don't know i don't think anybody
really wants that okay we made our
arguments
we watched cities burn we watched
buildings in cities burn
so that fox you know juan williams get
mad at me many buildings were destroyed
many businesses will never come back and
even in small towns
then the election happened and the
people decided
you know what i don't care about the
riots you know why
and because for the most part the cops
were there beating people up so i'm
gonna vote for
democrats the people who actually
supported the riots bailed them out
encouraged more
now the election is over and there are
cops
who in the previous story which talked
about the feds were planning on
arresting chauvin if he was if he was
acquitted
literally if the jury was like he has
not committed he is not guilty of this
crime they'd be like arrest him anyway
the cops who are remaining are propping
all of that up
because these people who virtue signal
can only sit back
like lazy wally characters sitting in
their their hover chairs morbidly obese
they could only do that because they
know the cops are going to clean up
their mess
so if you want to be a cop in this
climate where you could potentially go
to prison or about that cop who mocked
lebron james who gets suspended without
pay according to his friend
his friend says so so we'll see how that
story comes out the police are saying
well he shouldn't have done that
you want to be you want to be a cop in
this environment you want to prop
up the corrupt politicians who i
guarantee you will call you
begging for help the moment antifa shows
up at their house you want them to feel
safe great i'll tell you what
when you resign who do you think nancy
pelosi is going to call when antifa
shows up to her house again
they're going to call the police what do
we do sorry ma'am there's no cops here
anymore remember how
you as a democrat wanted to defund and
and rallied people against them what do
you think is going to happen in maxine's
maxine waters district she's the one who
came out and told everybody
that if you see someone from trump's
administration you get in their face you
confront them
and the people did what do you think
she's gonna do when auntie pushes up to
her house
and she calls does i need the police uh
ma'am
you led riots against the police
there's no one to come police protection
right
and then you see lebron james imagine
this i love this lebron james is a photo
of him in new york
and he's got all these nypd guys
guarding him you want to you want to
know what's really funny
those cops who protect i'll tell you
this there's two there's two two groups
of cops in
in new york the cops who protect lebron
from this point forward because that
phone is probably old
the most pathetic sniveling groveling
spineless losers if if if i was a cop
and i got a call and said hey we got
lebron james coming in can you guard him
i'd be like
no nice try dude he's on his own he
doesn't want our help
what what's gonna happen someone's gonna
pull out a knife i'm gonna try and save
him he's gonna get mad at me
not gonna happen but then you had these
cops in new york who were guarding the
black
lives matter mural now i love this you
know why
the mural was illegal it was literally a
crime
to paint the street de blasio did it
without a permit
using taxpayer dollars and then put 27
cops to guard it and people were
protesting and throwing paint on it and
the cops would arrest them
like sniveling little losers
imagine being as spineless and pathetic
as any one of those cops in new york
who's standing there half slouched where
a the the the the mayor
is smack talking you to your face in
front of everybody and then you're just
like
thank you deblasio i'll guard this for
you now wow it's like it's
it's it's like a randall from recess
that little kid
was always with miss miss finster and
he's like miss finster
grow a spine be an adult stand up for
yourself
it was disgusting to see cops literally
arresting protesters
to defend something that was that was
spitting in their face
you got to be a special kind of pathetic
loser to get slapped around
non-stop by corrupt politicians and then
still agree to
clean up their mess and protect them
from the mess they created
this is what bothers me the most when
kamala harris supports
the riots by soliciting funds to bail
these people out
in minnesota ongoing rights for a year
and then the cops are like
i'm going to protect her after that
where where where is any one of these
people with principle they don't exist
so
i'll tell you what really scares me the
cops that are leaving are the good cops
the ones who are saying i'm not going to
defend these corrupt politicians these
celebrities
and the ones remaining are like the the
cops that remain on the force
overwhelmingly not every single one
there's probably other reasons but
overwhelmingly
as i said the other day are the guys who
are going to sell out their own mothers
for cash they don't they don't care
about community they don't care about
this country they don't care about the
constitution
they just care about money and not even
a lot of it either
i mean man if you were gonna be a
pathetic loser you there's so many
there's so many other jobs that would
pay better
than licking the boots of bill de blasio
but i guess it tastes good
so you know good for them i think that's
by design man i i think
what these guys are black lives matter
and antifa
their their whole goal in narrative is
to
demonize cops right so i think
when they accomplish this i think that's
part of what they're attempting to do
like no matter what they do
they want to prove that cops are bad so
you get conservatives right you get
these
back the blue people that view stuff
like that what you're describing right
they see
cops defending black lives matter what
does that do
that paints in the mind of that
individual that wow these cops are
horrible
that in my opinion i think that further
pushes
their agenda and their narrative because
when you see those optics on tv
and people are experiencing this stuff
it further demonizes police officers
even if they're good cops so in my
honestly i think antifa and black lives
matter do
do that kind of stuff on purpose because
the optics of that
brings you to a conclusion to what you
literally just said to a lot of people
that don't realize that that's
by design i i wouldn't be willing to bet
that that's by design
i'm in favor of abolishing the police at
this point not for the leftist reasons
where they're screaming racism or
whatever
but because right now as it stands if a
leftist extremist gets arrested
the da will say sorry about that buddy
i'm so sorry the cop arrested you can go
home now no charges
and then you so much as fart and you get
arrested
and the da's gonna be like oh i'm gonna
lock you up and throw away the key
so the cops are like i'm just a new
neutral enforcer of the law
i arrest antifa and i arrest the people
on the right too and the people on the
right go to jail and get solitary
confinement
and the people on the left get let out
and do it again the cops
it's the banality of evil shuffling uh
i'll put it this way law a con someone
exercising their constitutional right to
keep and bear arms in a state like new
jersey
those cops with a smile on their face
will lock you up in two seconds
and the d.a will laugh as they bang the
gavel and say
shut your mouth you're going to prison
because you can't bear arms in new
jersey
you literally cannot bear arms in new
jersey period
you th this is a state where they say
you have to have a qualifying reason
to be able to bear arms so pretty sure
the right to bear arms has already been
infringed now you can keep them
if you go through a process and they're
in your home and they're you know in a
safe and if someone breaks into your
home
you run away but you can't run away with
the gun just can't bring the gun outside
so if you're in a house in new jersey
and someone breaks in don't grab the gun
run away because you're legally required
to
think about the logic there no joke it's
it in new jersey you have to retreat
from your own home
so what's the point of having the gun
you can't so here's what happens
how do you go to prison if you if you
have if you're bearing arms in new
jersey
it is a police officer who will
gleefully arrest you
and it's happened it happens to a lot of
people a lot of good law-abiding
citizens
simply make a mistake one story i was
told is that in in pennsylvania you
could bear arms
and if you live in philly the new jersey
side is literally a five-minute drive
uh-oh
what happens you take the wrong ramp
what happens if you're in philadelphia
with your legal gun
and you take the wrong exit and you go
oh no i'm crossing into new jersey it
was an accident i don't want to be here
and then you pull off the bridge and you
get pulled over and they say too bad
that cops gonna smile as you get a
felony and go to prison
or have your life destroyed they will
smile and you know what i i'm sure
they'll smile
as they arrest antifa then the antivirus
will get the per the
charges dropped and they'll get let go
and then you'll get to go to prison so
at this point
i'm just like the remaining cops are not
good cops i'd rather be responsible for
myself
if antifa can burn down buildings across
this country and get away with it
i need to defend myself and that's why i
started buying weapons to protect my
home and myself
as is my constitutional right and the
last thing i need
is a cop who can't enforce antifa but
will gladly lock me up if i try to
exercise my rights in the wrong place it
sounds like it's more problem with the
da's
because the cops are just impartially
arresting criminals whoever whether you
agree with the crime or not but then the
da's are letting these people go
so it's putting the cops in a in a bad
place the cops are the ones who are who
are enforcing it
well they're just the d.a isn't showing
up at my house and threatening to arrest
me no the d.a is letting the criminals
go
right yeah so if there were no cops
enforcing unconstitutional laws we
wouldn't have to worry about the d.a
would sit there crying with no support
but wielding the power of law
enforcement allows them to selectively
enforce political ideologies and they're
doing it
so last year the argument was stand up
for the police and vote
when that didn't work at this point the
cops are clearly
just getting good citizens arrested and
charged and antifa is getting let go
not just not just antifa but extremists
on the left black lives matter
these i mean we had in in portland i
think there were like
four people charged with felonies and
the feds charged them and the moment joe
biden gets in
all charges dropped and there's only so
so so then you look at what's going on
with you know proud boys or whatever
they get they get arrested
or or kyle rittenhouse or chauvin
i i think i think the show thinks
hilarious because he is a cop but you
look at
kim kim potter so long as the police are
willing to enforce this
they need to wake up and realize they
may be neutral enforcers of the law
but after the arrest the d.a is a
political actor who will let their
friends go and lock up anyone who
opposes them and it's
only possible because cops are doing it
i tell you what i'm done with it
the cops were unable to stop the riots
i'd rather defend myself
y'all can go home now to all these cops
who are resigning these guys are good
people they're good cops they're
respectable
they're refusing to suffer the indignity
and they're refusing to lick the boots
of these politicians but the ones who
remain these people are crooked as they
come
no principles they care not for their
community
they would stand there guarding an
illegal mural painted with taxpayer
dollars without the approval of the
taxpayer
and arrest people who challenged it it's
too i i think it's too extreme to make
judgments on on their on who they are
because you might have trash humans
resigning from the police department
right now yeah it's a generality
amazing people staying on the force with
limited options or
you know some altruistic motive ian if i
told you
like if someone came to you and they
were like you have to like brutally
like mercilessly beat a child otherwise
you have to be homeless which would you
pick
my god i'm not beating a kid so what if
they said you have to
here's an old woman who has a a a nine
millimeter in her purse
you have to lock her up for four years
in a state penitent penitentiary
otherwise you're homeless pick one well
i the cop doesn't
decide how long she gets locked up
because transports her to the to the
courthouse basically
yeah so so so let's see you encounter a
woman she's 65
she's got a little snub nose in her
purse and you as the cop are told
either you are losing your job or you're
going to bring this woman
in and she will go to prison pick one
you got to bring her in
why do you have to bring a woman why if
she violated the law and you're a cop
i thought i thought the constitution was
the supreme law of the land well that
it's a
that's a confusing thing whether it's a
state do you
think a 65 year old woman with a
revolver and a person go to prison for
four years
it's just a vague statement do you know
where she is man
minding her own business going to an atm
from her apartment she's scared is it
legal i don't know
no it's illegal it's illegal let's say
it's a 65 year old woman in chicago
and she knows there's a high gang crime
and people are shooting each other she
needs to go to the atm she's worried so
she gets a gun
she's walking down she robs nobody she
doesn't want a committee crime never
committed a crime in her life
should she go to prison i don't know
that's for the courts
you don't know no that's for the courts
to decide whether she gets let off or
put in jail
in prison the answer is not my decision
they're not the they're not the jury
they're not the i think
ian this is why i called you evil before
remember i said what yes i called you
evil this is the banality of evil
the idea that a 65 year old woman who is
not a criminal who is scared of gang
violence
wants to protect herself and is walking
to an atm i don't know if she should be
locked up for four years
she shouldn't be why should she be what
did she do nothing
that's just it's that's why we have
courts to decide that stuff i don't
think that ian is evil
i think that ian is a relativist which
comes out to be a little bit of a
problem if you're doing something like
being a cop
because the fact of the matter is that
you can be a neutral arbiter of a law
but if the law is bad
you become a force of bad i'm sorry
that's how
okay ian there's an old woman and she's
got a bag of weed in her purse
should she go to prison depends on where
she is in chicago
i don't know what's the laws man it's
illegal well the whole go to prison
thing is up to the court to decide
there are mandatory drug minimums in
illinois should an
old lady who has a small amount who has
well i think they decriminalized
but should should a person who wants to
imbibe a psychedelic go to prison for
choosing to do so
the answer is no i don't think
unequivocally
no i don't agree with those laws but
they are the laws so we have to change
the laws
to stop putting the pressure on the cop
cop
has every right not to enforce a law but
you gotta be careful with that if you're
a cop cops
can say go home kid yeah ma'am you can't
have that
you got to get rid of it you can submit
it to to the police station you can turn
it in but you can't have it because
someone else will lock you up but
probably if you how about
when the cop in new jersey stopped the
woman who crossed the bridge because
this is a story i was told that one of
the gun shops out there instead of
arresting her and
getting her and processing her and then
her getting charged with the felony he
goes ahead ma'am
i'm going to give you an escort back to
the on ramp to go across that bridge
back to pennsylvania you can't bring
that weapon into this state does that
sound okay
okay ma'am please let's go instead what
did he say
you're under arrest i got you and then
he brought her to the station and she's
going to go to prison why because she
crossed the bridge
amazing i mean that is the banality i
mean that's outright evil
i mean evil is when a cop is like i
don't care about the constitution
i don't care about morals or principles
i just think
who cares you get arrested let me jump
let me jump in this okay so
i just i just want to speak to police
officers right now and just give you
like a
a a real quick biblical perspective you
know
we we're living under an unrighteous
government that is
facilitating and enabling uh pure
lawlessness
on a grand scale um regardless of
whatever state you find yourself in
you know the the biblical mandate for a
police officer
is literally in romans chapter 12 god's
avenger
that is mandated to execute righteous
judgment
or justice upon evil doers so what i
want people to understand and think
about right now especially if you're a
police officer
you're going to have to really make a
decision i know this is a lot easier
said than done
and i'm just giving you some kind of
like pastoral counsel right now you guys
know what i'm talking about
you're gonna have to make a decision
right now whether you are going to
be a vessel of lawlessness
and execute unrighteousness under an
unrighteous lawless government because
that is what you are
literally becoming that's where america
is because they're not executing
righteous judgment
or you're gonna have to make a decision
and walk away
from what this system literally is right
now and like i said
i know that's a lot easier said than
done you're thinking about your family
you're thinking about your future you're
thinking about your kids schools you're
thinking about your reputation
but i got to be honest with you man like
in in terms of what god has called
you to be and to do you are now heading
in a direction where you are not
uh god's avenger of executing righteous
judgment on evil doers
you're actually becoming the opposite
you're actually becoming the evil doer
to execute
unrighteousness on the innocent so i say
this to say this
is you're gonna have to make that
decision as to
what you want to be a part of and what
you become right now in 2021 moving
forward because right now things are not
getting any better
and you're gonna have to make some
serious sacrifices and
and really you know place your faith and
where god really wants you to be because
you i mean how do you want your kids to
view you how do you want your
your legacy to become because right now
i'm going to be honest this is what
separates me tim
from a lot of other conservatives like
in the movement i am not a
100 back the blue guy these people hate
me for this i get all kinds of messages
the who's the matter with you what do
you mean that's what we believe i'm like
no no no
because when you end up in a police
state who the hell is the police right
so
those are my views like for me tim i
agree with you right i agree with you
with what you're saying but what
what i want to add to that is police
officers have to make a choice
i agree with you let me know what you're
saying ian let me ask you a question you
said that it depends on what the law is
right
the cops should just follow the law well
no the cop has a moral judgment
call to make oh okay so you're not
you're saying the cops shouldn't just
lock up an old woman who who didn't
commit
i didn't say she he should or shouldn't
it depends on the situation i mean that
one
i asked you a specific instance an old
woman going to an atm in chicago she's
scared of gang violence and so she buys
a gun and she has it with her the cop
you know what's up should she go to
prison i don't know man that's up to the
cop really
would you arrest her not to prison but
to take her to jail that would be a cop
you know she's going to prison like you
you can't pass the buck you know she's
going to prison
so would you do it would you arrest her
for that i would resign as a cop
immediately if i was a cop
that's the point yeah i'm not i'm not
i'm not i'm not a kind of
you know you know how to because you
know the point is
loading jews onto trains was the law
and there were a lot of people who
didn't know what they were doing but it
was the law they had to do it it is the
obligation
of our cops our military to defy
unlawful orders now we talked about this
the other day the challenge is
what if you don't know what the end
result is now you've got a moral
challenge
that's why i think the national guard in
the military would probably just follow
the orders they're given because they
don't know the full context
and they can't but when it comes to a
cop who's looking at a young person
who's got a small amount of drugs
or some sort and they think to
themselves i'm going to arrest this
person
they know what comes next they're not
making these people's lives better
now for the most part look drugs are
illegal and i'm not a big fan
i i do think the war on drugs is bad but
specifically around the right to defend
ourselves right now is my issue
the police are trying to arrest these
people they almost
always get let go and i'll give you one
more in dc
in 2017 several hundred people got
arrested all at the same time
i was in that group i got released
because i was calm and polite
talked to the cops showed him my press
id eventually they pulled me out let me
go
not only did these people get
their charges dropped they then sued the
city
after running around smashing windows
and setting fires
and they won a massive lawsuit the
taxpayer
is now paying the people who set garbage
on fire
set an immigrant's limousine on fire
which he didn't own it was leased
and they smashed up windows and
buildings got arrested
but they know the tactics and the
strategies so they said the government
didn't know how to charge the
individuals they couldn't
so they get their charges dropped and
then they turned around and sued the
city and
won sued the government and won so
my problem right now is as
it doesn't matter what what you think
the cops should or shouldn't be doing
doesn't matter what i think what matters
is
at the political level the judges
the mayors and at the federal level are
control
controlled by the cult by the cathedral
and any cop who stands there saying i'm
just neutral arbiter of the law
you are handing people over to the cult
so at this point i'm like you know
whatever abolish the police i guess at
least then maybe people in this country
will start taking responsibility for
their own lives and security
and the virtue signalers who who prance
around not caring about what's going on
might be shocked into waking up because
right now they're just frogs boiling in
a pot
but if all the cops walked off then
you'd have these people lying on the
suburbs of chicago
making a phone call saying hey help
something's happening outside my house i
need help ma'am there's no cops anymore
we abolished them where were you
you were supporting this but i do have
some good news
i'm not going to be constantly negative
because we got news ladies and gentlemen
this one's big from abc what is this is
okay it's interesting this is from
abc 17 fox 22
both the same time there you go
minnesota man
sentenced to four years in prison for
role in setting ablaze a minneapolis
police precinct
during floyd protests they say dylan
shakespeare robinson 23 pleaded guilty
in december
to one count of conspiracy to commit
arson for taking part
in setting up police precinct in
minneapolis on fire on may 28th days
after
floyd was pinned down and you know
another story robinson was sentenced
wednesday to four years in prison
and two years of supervised release
according to a news released from the
news release from the district of
minnesota's u.s attorney's office he was
also ordered to pay 12 million dollars
in restitution
robinson's attorney has not responded to
cnn's request for comment so i guess to
cnn's story
you want to know why this story is funny
because he only got four years do you
want
but you want to know why he got any time
at all because he burned down the police
station that's right
because when push comes to shove the
system will protect itself and not you
what about the people who burn down the
sports bar what about the people who
threatened the guy in his home and this
is important a guy
he's got an american flag at his house
they go up to his house and start
chanting just random guy
and they start yelling take the flag
down or burn your house down no charges
there
people in dc they actually got paid for
it so
i know this guy's a he's a local
celebrity you know that right oh they
love him yeah he's gonna be a political
prisoner to be a hero
and when i was when i was in minneapolis
a couple weeks ago and uh
the specifically black lives matter
because sometimes people throw blm like
very loosely you know this was blm in
minneapolis
one of the activists one of the leaders
got up and was like
you all know that some of these are
they're being they're facing charges
of arson because they burnt down that
police station last year
she's like yeah you know you guys all
remember that she's like that was that
that stuff was effing epic
they love it so what do you think
happens he's a celebrity in
in four or five years okay so maybe
trump
trump you know trump is talking about
running again in 2024
i don't think trump's got the uh
gumption to actually get the job done i
don't
i think a lot of people thought he was a
fighter turns out not not really
i mean it's better than biden it's
better to have someone who's resisting
the system than supporting it
but i don't even think trump's got what
it takes maybe ron desantis does
but what do you think happens if trump
doesn't win if they continue to gain
more and more power this guy is going to
get out
and when he walks out there's going to
be local politicians clapping and
cheering
they already voted to abolish the police
it kind of backfired now they're
desperate for cops
but what do you think happens if this if
this ideology keeps persisting a slow
boil
by the time this guy in four years is
getting out of jail the local mayor is
going to be like you're a hero and we're
so sorry that you're a political
prisoner
you'll get released i think because what
the mainstream media has done
is they this is why you see this on cnn
msnbc
abc they'll always call them
either peaceful protesters or they'll
call them just protesters
right protests erupt after the
shooting of dante wright right every
single black person that gets shot
protests even fox will say this protests
erupt protest protest and i'll show you
a picture of like a building burning
down right yeah but
but listen to the the my my theory on
this
if you if you're constantly putting the
narrative out that these are
protesters whenever the headline comes
out the next day that a hundred people
got arrested
that sounds horrible right a hundred
protesters
got arrested last night for what
expressing their first amendment right
of freedom of speech
and to peacefully protest right that's
just the narrative
but it works because nobody wants their
name attached to the headline the next
morning no mayor
no d.a no police depart nobody wants
that headline the next morning saying
a hundred protesters got arrested last
night
for expressing their first amendment
right nobody wants that but
that's the propaganda but that's why in
my opinion it works that's why they get
away with writing
that they get glorified when they burn
down a building antifa is continuing to
burn down
police union buildings with people in it
the only reason or i should say one of
the strongest reasons one of the main
reasons
that people in major urban metros keep
voting democrat
is because the cops are propping the
system up
what do you think what happened when
they voted to abolish the police in
minneapolis
crime skyrocketed and locals started
panicking
calling their city councilmen being like
what's happening where are the police
why is this happening
and then all of a sudden these pro
abolish the police people come back and
say we
we need our cops back our constituents
are freaking out did the
uh portland cops just all 200 resign
like today
was that seattle over the past several
months okay so imagine what would happen
if the remaining cops were like you're
on your own
this is what i was talking about with
lydia on the drive here from the airport
is
i think there are times in history where
you're either gonna learn from you know
data
facts knowledge wisdom and make your
decisions from there
or you're gonna have to learn through
experience so i think right now america
is so spoiled so self-entitled
where socialism is like and communism
are like glorified
ideas but we have no idea what it feels
like to live under something like that
i think right now we are going in a
direction tim where
as a christian i think i believe we're
either going to experience some kind of
spiritual revival people are going to
come to christ and things are going to
change or
i think we'll probably have some kind of
civil war people are going to push back
and say enough is enough we're fed up
with the communists
get out of here right or i think we're
just gonna have to continue going down
this path
people are gonna keep voting blue people
are gonna keep supporting these radicals
people are gonna keep virtue signaling
bowing down to black lives matter and
antifa
right and we're just gonna have to get
burnt because i think right now the
country's going in the direction like
you said minneapolis like
abolish the police oh maybe that wasn't
such a good idea
you know like so i think on a grand
scale that's where we're going where
i think we're going to have to watch the
republic fall in order for us to
pick up the pieces again and just say
that's what they were i know that's what
they i trust
that was their mission that's their
mission that's their goal but people
don't realize that like you said like
you you were telling me earlier people
aren't listening
they just don't care it's like okay well
you're gonna care when these people are
knocking down
your down door uh knocking down your
damn door at night when they want to
take your life and call you a white
supremacist but
like i said i think we're going down
that path where it's just gonna have to
get to that point
where people feel it they feel what
these ideas do and until you get there
you're not gonna
really understand so as long as the cops
are still around to answer calls
for the uppity white progressives who
are leading the charge and making all
this bad stuff happen
the same people who say abolish the
police are the ones who yell call 9-1-1
when they're threatened
and then who suffers the poor the
minority neighborhoods
the ones who according to gallup are
saying they want more cops but
won't stand up and actually actually ask
for them i'll tell you this here's a
simple compromise
if you're a cop just don't answer any
calls to uh
these uppity progressive areas if if you
get one of these
you know wealthy liberal areas saying
you know help someone's breaking into my
house i'll be like well do you have a
gun
no you know geez i was i was like i
guess i was talking about this with some
some of my some of my buddies in
minneapolis and i was just like you know
i don't know if i would say this out
loud but i'm gonna say it out loud
would it have been better for derek
shelvin to just let george floyd go
yes well we don't know because if he was
really high on fentanyl and he was
getting behind the wheel of a car he
might have killed a family that's true
too
but i i understand well like there's so
many things that
could go wrong and a cop is obligated to
think about that right but
what i'm trying to say is i think cops
are starting to ask themselves
was was that even worth it i mean i'm
i am i am going to lose my life i'm
going to lose my family
i i am going to lose everything over a
guy that had a
20 counterfeit bill and it led to the
fbi
gonna come at uh the fbi was interested
no matter what everyone agrees on at
this point
well i should say for the most part the
left has been saying that the whole time
who cares there's a 20 bill let him go
but there's a bigger issue
the guy was doing drugs behind the wheel
of a vehicle
and now you've got some serious
questions about like ian said what if he
yeah hit somebody i agree i agree with
that especially the way that i think
that's the first thing that where my
mind goes do you have a fentanyl addict
that could get loose in the community
and he could literally wreak havoc right
but it would have been objectively
better for the cops not to have
responded
and from this point on not to respond at
all yikes that's
what i think people are asking
themselves and it's like i i personally
think the answer to that question
is no but i'm just putting that question
out because i think that's what a lot of
cops are beginning to ask themselves and
it's just another subversion
of law and order but it's it's it's such
a crazy situation because another thing
that i wanted to point out and i want
people to understand is
all you hear from black lives matter is
that george floyd
uh died because he was black okay even
the head of the prosecution went on 60
minutes the other night and literally
claimed that this was not a hate crime
that they had zero evidence to prove
that george floyd
was targeted because of the color of his
skin this is part of the propaganda that
is leading to people burning down
buildings
okay committing mass looting mass arson
that's all you hear tim you know what
i'm talking about whenever you're at a
blm
rally or antifa direct action black
people getting hunted
black people getting shot black people
are dying at the hands of police
officers
it's it's a fact it's a fact the
prosecution
admitted george floyd did not die
because of the color of his steve nelson
said it why why wasn't he charging the
head of the prosecution there was no
evidence
there was no evidence yeah well but look
where we are
right abolishing police burning down
buildings
rioting causing over two billion dollars
of damage in 2020 alone
over a lie drew i think that i honestly
am starting to think that what happened
in minneapolis needs to happen to every
city where these
uppity white progressives are calling to
abolish the police you
should have that moment of fear where
you need to call the police
and nothing happens yeah i don't want
riots
i don't want buildings being burned i
just want people to like
they'll see someone walking through
their neighborhood and they'll call the
police and the cops are going to be like
good luck yeah that would be good if
everyone had to psychologically
experience the trauma of not having
police but my fear
i love the idea of police and military
refusing to serve a corrupt regime that
i love that idea
but what terrifies me if all the police
vanish tomorrow
and all these private cops and federal
cops come in to fill the void
and it becomes it's worse than it was
before that would be worse because
private cops don't have to adhere to the
city okay
stop to adhere to the law it's supposed
to yeah ian the cops that we have right
now people who are serving out bad laws
people who are doing unethical things
are essentially
mercenaries so you want to talk about
someone who's paid to do something
that's not moral not ethical and that's
not a single eye when they're asked to
do something like arrest a little
tiny old lady i think ian i think you're
wrong because if someone calls police
hut
i'll call you know policies junior oh
yeah and i'll have my
my you know police huh but you're two
months behind on your policy junior bill
so oh i won't be yeah
well yeah i won't be so so a lot of
people are talking uh
i see a lot of comments where people are
saying there will be a vacuum of power
without the police department
do you live in a big democrat urban
metro well then i'll tell you this
you shouldn't i left we all left we were
in the philadelphia area and i was like
man i see where this is going
i'm out am i really that worried about a
power vacuum in the middle of nowhere
where there's already no power structure
other than people in their own homes
on large multi-acre properties who are
armed to the teeth
ain't got nothing to worry about out
here good luck coming to west virginia
and having a go with a ride in one of
these neighborhoods these
these people live in west virginia
there's there's facebook group chats
there's text chats
and the moment they don't they don't
call the cops they just text the group
they're like hey you know i saw somebody
keep your eyes keep pressing
on the lookout some of these people
scare me
they're like oh man you know the cities
are so lucky can't wait for these people
to come out here i'm like nah you don't
want to say that dude that's that's
freaky we don't want to do that
but i'm not worried now i'm not worried
in the least bit
we don't we don't have a police station
out here in the same way a city does
we're in a place where you call the cops
we'll be there in what
an hour i mean that might be true in the
cities too by the way because
cities i don't know they're pretty
crummy in a lot of ways
so power vacuum in the city well the
people who voted for this
and keep voting for democrats hey that's
on them if you think there's gonna be a
power vacuum filled by a bunch of
corrupt private cops
gangs and woke police
do you live there i mean i'm sure a lot
of people do and they're probably
freaked out by this
but at a certain point take
responsibility and get out i mean look
like like i've been saying your house is
on fire now we we all fought very hard
to reject that fire and shut it down
now it's clear the fire is engulfing
your house now you need to go outside oh
but it's cold outside i know
but what about my family they'll freeze
that's true but they'll burn to death if
you stay inside
so maybe it's already that point where
all these cops are leaving crime is
already skyrocketing
you want to tell me there's a power
vacuum have you been paying attention to
the crime rates in all major cities
across the country
shootings are up like 250 percent or
something in new york
why are you still there well look if
your house is on fire no one's coming to
save you you got to save yourself
maybe that's the point about these
people living in these cities for
everybody else who kind of lives outside
the cities or in the middle of nowhere
what are you worried about or get out of
the blue states at the very least
stop living in places where they put
their boot on your neck and let
criminals run rampant
i think i think that goes back to what i
was saying earlier is i think police
officers have to make a choice
you have a constitutional oath to
protect and to serve the communities
that you work under
and i think it goes back to also like
the leadership if the leadership is
setting you up
to fail miserably to the point where you
can't even protect yourself in some
cases
you look at portland i'm in contact with
portland pd on a daily basis almost
and they always tell me the mayor is in
control of all of this
we get our hands tied behind our back we
can't even use the type of
riot training that we've been trained to
to use
to stop these people and then you see
the footage and it's just cops getting
milk shake
just humiliated the psychological abuse
that goes into that as well
i talk to them this is what they tell me
they live in fear they they fear their
lives they fear
uh antifa finding out where they live
but the point i'm trying to make is
i think i think tim is what these these
these police officers do have to
sincerely consider am am i
walking into a profession where i'm
being set up to fail now
i think anyone would be like i'm not
going to work for that i don't care
about these cops in portland
i saw the video of the blue lives matter
people getting shoved by cops while they
protected antifa who had pepper spray
you think i'm going to give any sympathy
to the guys who are shutting down small
businesses
arresting a guy for handing out a beer
or or shoving and pushing
the peaceful right-wing protesters who
actually support the police
nah that's the problem the d.a will
throw the book at someone on the right
and they'll let someone left go with no
charges and the cops will arrest both
and say don't look at me
that's what i'm saying so antifa goes
around throwing fire bombs setting fires
and then when the when the right-wing
group shows up the cops form a line
hold their batons out start shoving them
and yelling and it was funny to see the
look on the face of these conservatives
like why are we being attacked by cops
and then taking the blue lives matter
flag throwing in the dirt and stomping
on it yeah and and i agree that's why a
lot like i told you a lot of
conservatives don't like me when i talk
like this
because i'm not 100 back to blue because
i don't support crooked cops i don't
support
unconstitutional cops i support cops
that support
their constitutional oath and they
actually protect and serve the
communities
if that's not what you're doing you need
to resign like tonight because that's
what you have been called to do
that's what you've been hired to do and
if you are being put in a position where
you cannot do that then
then i know this is a lot easier said
than done you got to really
reconsider if this is the profession
that you want because now we live in a
generation
where lawlessness is now abounding that
means
that you have to be a crooked cop to
survive now
that's a pretty radical thing to have to
swallow but that's where we are
the media is lying antifa is not real
the politicians it's just an idea and
the district attorney's
you're free to go all of this is only
possible
because cops are protecting those who
keep pushing for it
plain and simple it is the uppity white
progressives in big cities who are
voting the democrats
giving them this power and they're only
able to do it because cops are standing
guard while antifa burns down minority
neighborhoods in poor neighborhoods
yeah it's like that funny tweet from
that guy who was like
yeah go riot woohoo wait a minute oh no
they're coming to my house in beverly
hills help stop don't do it you see what
you see you see what happens to these
people
the moment the riders show up to their
neighborhoods but it's okay
because i assure you the cops will be
there to protect the rich people i love
it in
in manhattan during hurricane sandy and
the power gets shut out
i tell you the first place to get their
power back do you know which part of new
york had their power back first
upper west side all the very very rich
people in the university
got to put their feet up while the
people in the poor areas in brooklyn
didn't have power i think it was for
like weeks regarding um
being set up to fail which it does seem
like a lot of these cops are
by these district attorneys when you're
in like high stress situations
people will do crazy things when they're
being set up to fail like in world war
one they'd be told to go over the
trenches they would just eventually just
mutiny and not go
in vietnam if you had a lieutenant that
was going to take you
down a trail where you knew you were
going to get shot that lieutenant would
find a grenade in his tent in the middle
of the night they called it fragging
for a reason because they would kill
their commanding officers if they were
going to
get them killed now we're not in that
high stress situation domestically right
now and the cops
aren't in the military they can resign
and
at one point chauvin had his life
destroyed because he tried to
this girl that shot the guy that was a
girl that was about to stab someone or
that guy that
oh yeah his life's going to be torched
because he saved
him kim potter was trying to make an
arrest on a guy
who was wanted on an aggravated robbery
warrant who was
armed and she shot him one time and he
died
and now she's going to go to prison kyle
rittenhouse
watched his community get burned hit
i'll i'll be very careful for juan
williams
watched businesses all throughout his
community burn get set on fire
they almost blew up a gas station
so and drew is there and he shows up and
a friend gives him a weapon
he even rendered aid to the extremists
now he's i think he's going to get life
in prison i do he'll get life
no jury is gonna is going to do anything
for justice or principle they're gonna
be like
you know what the kid can can go to
prison for all i care i don't want to
get hurt
because of demoralization and it's only
possible because there are cops who
arrested him
because they're like well you know it's
the system at what point is there
someone who's going to be like
there's right and there's wrong
i just think we sound like mexico now
this is what the cartel does right i
mean you you take a look at what
happened with chauvin right
uh you guys covered it the other night
the alternate juror literally came out
and was like
i was pretty much scared that riots
would come and
not pretty much literally i did not want
to go through riots and destruction
again
and i was scared someone would come to
my house to retaliate right so that that
that is by design because what was
happening right
you had someone that took the stand
right
they were blm antifa show up to their
house they're throwing pigs blood
pigs heads on their front door
threatening themselves the witness
the witness that's in california though
sending a message it doesn't matter
where it is
this sends a message across the u.s bro
that is literally what
cartels do that but take it a step
further they'll send a human head to
your house they'll hang someone from
highways highways they'll send a message
they they threaten media the same way
black lives matter is and antifa are are
slowly going in that direction where
it's not going to be animal pigheads
it's going gonna be humans man
it's a very extreme thing for me to say
but this is what happens in foreign
countries like mexico
they're like the strong arm media and
police officers and even the military
so what do you think happens then if the
police departments are all gone
a lot of people think it's going to be
rampant crime everywhere i don't think
so
i think in cities it'll be bad i think i
already live in an area without a police
department so i don't care
i think people will especially in the
big blue cities
um in terms of okay blm wants to police
themselves
right so let's think about the ohio
video
right mikaya bryant just picture that
video without the cop there
that's what it would look like and so
everyone seems to be okay with that yeah
black people kicking each other in the
head stabbing each other in the throat
but outside of race just people in
cities in general
what do you think is going to happen to
these upper west side
progressives who are very wealthy in new
york when the cops are gone i think
they're gonna freak out
i think these are the same people that
are voting for gun control laws as well
oh yeah right so these are the same
morons that dumb
they don't put two and two together it's
like hey biden is saying let's let's you
know your second amendment right means
nothing it's not an absolute
right he says that amendment is not an
absolute oh but by the way we're gonna
abolish the cops so
uh yeah you can't call 9-1-1 whenever
you need someone to save your life
if the people in the upper west side of
new york vote for this i say
good for them congratulations i don't
live there if they don't want cops they
don't get cops but i tell you this
we've already seen what's going on in
new york city we've already heard from
these people
they are starting to panic because the
cops don't show up anymore because
they're all gone
i think that goes back to what i said
people are going to have to experience
it
they're going to have to feel it because
if you don't feel it then you're never
going to know what it really
looks like or even feels like i wouldn't
necessarily frame it that way it's more
like they must
understand why they have to take
responsibility for themselves
i'm sick of everyone just being like
someone else will do it for me yeah the
government should give me money
the government should pay for all of my
bills the cops should protect me
i don't protect myself and if i get hurt
it's your fault i'll sue you and then
you give me money
yeah no that's what they want yeah
people got to be responsible for them
responsible
you do want public options of defense
because
if if you have to protect yourself and i
have to protect myself and then you step
on my door
on my doorstep then and someone gets
killed
like that's a bad situation you want the
cop to be the one to decide
who was right who was wrong no no you
stopped to basically create the peace to
keep the peace well you want a neutral
arbiter between
conflicted factions to de-escalate to
stop the conflict but that doesn't
always happen cops go in and they're
going
to
protect themselves first and foremost
people need to be responsible
but people have lost responsibility
because we keep having the government do
things for them
and now they're just becoming lazy and
disinterested and demoralized
people need to have purpose they need to
have hard work
but they wake up every day with
everything being done for them
in this wealthy society and they have no
purpose
so the system is on fire specifically
because
the the people who inherited this wealth
from the previous generation don't know
how that wealth was built
it's like they say you know like wealth
lasts three generations
the first person makes all the money
because they work really hard
they then raise their child to
understand hard work but the kid grows
up pretty rich
and then kind of maintains it a little
bit the next kid who grows up doesn't
experience the hard work at all
because her grandpa's long been retired
they inherit all the money and then it
all vanishes after the third generation
that's what's happening right now for
the country we had the we had world war
ii we had people fighting
sacrificing to to literally defeat
nazism and fascism
they come back to this country and boom
business is a booming
life was good then we get the next
generation hippie dippies
doing hippy dippy stuff and then we have
the next couple of generations where
it's just we've inherited all of this
wealth we don't know how it was built
and we're
squandering it as it just evaporates in
front of us
maybe it's time people you know hey
whether we want it or not hard times are
coming yeah and hard times make strong
men
that's right and that's just how it goes
isn't it so maybe it doesn't matter
maybe maybe time is like a river
you can move around within the river but
the but the time is a flowing
in that direction but you know hard
times do make strong men
well theoretically but you don't know
which
who these strongmen are going to be i
think we talked about this when we had
ben stewart on talk about the fourth
turning that
if there was some cataclysm and some
chaos hard times you know world war
that maybe it would be the chinese that
would win and become the strong men
afterwards so it doesn't mean that we
will become the strong men if we enter
the hard times we may be
wiped out as a result you could be very
careful
looking for well let's let's jump to the
current state of the union
where where are we right now are we
entering hard times i think the answer
is yes then we have some metrics to back
that up
from deadline joe biden's address to
congress snares
26.9 million viewers hey 26.9 million
that's what like uh three times the
oscars
that's oh yeah yeah yeah but no no
that's that's what how many people voted
uh so that's 81 million
yeah so uh 30 percent of the apparently
wow so not a whole lot of people but but
26.9 that's surely a good number
way down from trump oh wait wait wait
hold on a minute way down he's left
hold on a minute you mean to tell me
that donald trump got 47.7 million
viewers
in his first speech to a joint session
on february 28th
okay oh okay so so all right all right
you know
it's a it's a is a little bit more than
half it's not that bad we're still good
i'm sure of the people who watched
you know joe biden speak considering
they were much less people
right it was probably way more people
who actually liked biden yeah definitely
so i'm sure
i'm sure the polling is going to be
really good for biden and we can breathe
a sigh of relief
i actually have a cnn article seven in
ten who watched biden's speech
said it left them feeling optimistic
okay that's good so uh
all right considering that there was you
know way less people
it makes sense that biden would have
pulled better than donald trump
uh they say the 51 percent
who had a very positive view positive
reaction abide in speech is a bit more
more muted than reaction to the first
address from other recent presidents
wait a minute wait wait what
51 that's a good number right yeah what
what what was what was donald trump
surely less than that 57 oh
with more viewers donald trump had more
people with a very positive reaction to
his speech
yeah we're not doing too well even the
people who voted for biden don't care
about biden
no they voted against trump that's right
and so you can't function as a society
when you have no cohesion
so now we have we we had a we have we
have a political
institution built upon hating donald
trump who's gone
that's it trump he's he's chilling he's
playing golf
so now the people who are like well
trump's gone we're done now it's just a
hollow shell
there's nothing there there's no
substance to the biden administration
right
all i was seeing yesterday the headlines
biden's first 100 days address
to congress oh wow kamala harris the
first woman to sit behind
biden with nancy pelosi that like that's
listen i'm not against like firsts right
for for women for minorities i think
that's cool i think that's awesome but
i think it's awesome when they actually
have done something
and when they've actually accomplished a
lot from the country
kamala harris did accomplish something
oh yeah california
she is the first woman to become vice
president after earning
zero delegates in the democratic party
huge first
here's the thing you see them all
celebrating
kamala harris right you see all these
articles it's all about race it's all
about gender it's all about sex
no substance right no accomplishments no
real accomplishments okay she did lock
up those innocent people to use a slave
labor during the wildfires yeah but the
thing is right now keep them locked up
i'm sorry i'm sorry everybody fact check
them out she is the border czar
apparently right
she she's the one that is supposed to be
overseeing what's taking place with the
border and
i think this is where a lot of
minorities people that don't think about
these things
they get manipulated it's like look at
the first woman to sit behind
a male during a congressional address
it's like well has she done anything
no no she's the first woman yeah yeah
yeah do you like this
continue to see it because that's what
you should care about it's like well we
still have a human
a strategic humanitarian crisis at the
southern border they're not doing
anything to better it they're actually
facilitating it they're
actually trying to sweep it under the
rug by unofficially gagging
border patrol agents and i can confirm
that because i've talked to them
when you go up and you interview them at
the southern border they literally the
first thing they tell you is
i can't talk to you but uh here's what's
going on you know what i'm trying to say
tim
is we should not be glorifying and
celebrating politicians
just because of their gender their sex
or even the color of their skin
when they're not doing anything to
better the country
kamala harris should not be celebrated
because she's not doing anything
especially with what's going on at the
southern border why didn't they address
it last night
you know what i really love about i mean
that's going on is that
over the past four years it's not just
the political landscape that's been
that's their whole identity is trump
sucks but the entire
media environment built an audience that
specifically just
hated donald trump yeah you'd think the
border crisis would be
as what did that technical directorate
cnn say gangbusters for ratings
he said covid was you'd think right now
they would be like crisis at the border
but their audience only cares about
trump
yeah so what are they going to report on
if they come out and talk about the
crisis of the border
the people who care about real news left
a long time ago yeah
so they can't yeah they don't give a
damn so you have all of these huge big
breaking stories conflict with ukraine
and russia
you've got now the u.s firing at iranian
you know uh
boats there were like military ships a
little little uh not chips boats
and now you've got the crisis at the
board which has been ongoing
i mean normally the media loves this
stuff if they leave
leads rights well they do care the
problem is
it makes some money and clicks if you
have a hundred million
that's all that's all we imagine this
you have 100 million core viewers and
then donald trump gets elected
so you scream about trump all of a
sudden your rankings up to 110. you're
like whoa
but what you don't realize you actually
lost 10 million core
news fans and gained 20 million
zealots over time your ratings are
improving
but you're actually losing all of the
people who care about news and gaining
zealots
what happens now trump leaves the
zealots leave for the most part
the people who care about news left
years ago people like me i used to have
cnn for the news
cnn on for the news and then they
weren't talking about anything fox news
covering protesting iran turn on cnn
donald trump today i don't care i turned
it off i don't watch it anymore
you if you want to go to news you can't
go to cnn anymore
so now they have to ignore these things
now they have to ignore the border
crisis
it's not just that it's bad for biden
yeah so their whole audience is
anti-trump
some of it pro-biden if they come out
now and say there's a crisis people are
gonna get mad at him
they've lost any credibility they've had
the media
is a is a withered husk of its former
self
what someone graffiti trump sucks on and
i don't think anybody's really
interested in standing at the thing
anymore
this is why i just i hope people
listening they they they hear this and
they understand that they're being
used i'm going to preach this until
there's no more lungs in my breath
because
minority is a special breath a normal a
breath in my lungs because
i'm very passionate about this because
people need to understand that they are
literally being used as political pawns
like
really think about this see through this
why is it just exactly what tim just
explained
why is it just because trump is not in
office they're not talking about the
border anymore when it's worse
than it was under trump but then these
are the same people you have
you have chris cuomo and you have don
lemon and you have
uh brian stelter you have all these
virtue signalers on cnn every single
night saying oh we care so much about
the black people we care so much about
the minorities but they're not reporting
what's taking place at the southern
border
there are literally migrants right now
by the hundreds by the thousands
that are being stuffed into trucks and
stash houses in the united states by the
cartels
against their will that is that is not
migration that is not immigration that
is human trafficking
by the hour by the minute listen i gotta
say this tim
because cnn won't say it msnbc won't say
it but they'll sit there and they'll
continue to virtue signal like they care
about us
but they don't because if they did just
to go literally to your point
they only do it for clicks and for
ratings and when it's a political attack
against a conservative or donald trump
they won't talk about it because they
don't care and i need people to
understand
they don't listen minorities tim you
know this minorities believe that these
people care about them well
they don't care about us overwhelmingly
voting for democrats yes year after year
after year after year after year
the past election seeing a lot of
latinos vote republican not that i like
the republican party but just getting
with the democrats at least
is it gives me some optimism and then
just thinking about the media
kind of failing and fumbling and joe
biden's ratings collapsing
actually i'm kind of feeling pretty good
about that we
you know we're we're on the roller
coaster and we're you're maybe about to
come to the bottom or to go back up
maybe things are going to change
maybe it it is it's maybe it's not as
bad as it can get
the night is always darkest before the
dawn but watching these media companies
fail to be able to do the oscars oscars
are over they put out a statement they
were like it's trump's fault for giving
everyone covet
nobody cared the oscars is trash joe
biden
speaks as president nobody cares he's a
trash president
that gives me some optimism i like it
not that i think trump is the is the
savior of the republic or anything
he's better than biden but maybe now we
might actually get something
better in 2024 it's like having not like
ron desantis is perfect either but
he's better than trump it's like we got
a crappy boat captain
and that we put in charge so but at
least people are acknowledging
he's a crappy boat captain but yeah he
might end up
listening to a glacier so we got to keep
that in mind donald trump
was flying a plane and the plane was
kind of bumpy because the whole time
you had other people bang on his door
and rocking everything and then blaming
him for the turbulence
he was trump was a braggart he was
boastful
and he kind of changed directions quite
a bit it's the best weather
the best the best turbulence everybody
listen
there's turbulence it's okay it's good
everybody actually enjoys it
it's kind of nice you know some people
yeah
is banging on the cockpit door making it
impossible
it's the best terminals you've ever seen
people people were were angry
and in part because of things trump
failed to do yes and
in part because they were riled up and
raged by the democrats so then they vote
to swap out the pilot with
biden who fell asleep and now the plane
is just
and we're all just like sitting this is
laughing in the co-pilot scene
no she stand behind it smiling elbow
bumping nancy pelosi got a pillow
i think i think the propaganda i think
the propaganda is so powerful
through disney through mainstream media
through cnn
through the mainstream music industry
every channel of art that you see i
think i think the propaganda is so
powerful that they are really convincing
people
um that they are the majority that the
radical neo-marxists and the
anarchists and antifa and all the sjws i
think they are
successfully painting the picture in the
minds of millions of people that they
are actually the majority in this
country
i don't think they are yeah i think it's
quite the opposite i think there are a
lot of
not just conservatives um centrists
people that are pro-america
pro-patriotism
they want to see their country succeed
they want to build their own empire and
wealth in this country they could really
care less about race or any of these
things
i think there are a lot more of us than
there are them and i think the
mainstream media is really painting the
picture successfully
that there's more of them than there are
us so i think more people need to wake
up to that reality and i encourage
people man i was telling lydia this in
the car on the way here too is like
let's be thankful that we are in a place
right now
where all that's happening to us that
disagree and speak out against the
mainstream media or narrative
is we get cancelled let's let's just
thank god that's kind of where it is
right now
and we're not getting killed yet over
this because i think that's where we are
going
so i encourage people to get involved
listen you may not be the next tim pool
you may not be the next jew hernandez or
you name it right but
wherever you are specifically in your
life we need more people
that have these pro-america views to get
active in their communities
especially education law order all these
avenues mainstream media all of it
people need to seriously start speaking
up right now it might be the next ian
crossland
it's possible yeah yeah you'll be used i
don't think i don't think ian's evil tim
you'll beat the banality of evil do you
think ian's evil i think he's an evil
villain but it's it's the banality of
evil so when people hear the word evil
they think it's
dr evil but the banality of evil is
someone saying well you know
the law says i have to do it so i'm
gonna do it
i'm very much uh i love i'm i'm way more
like uh
chaotic and anarch anarchist
kistic than it seems i you know i have
to be kind of
level for for the world for tv and all
that but man
i am a revolutionary at heart uh i can't
stand evil laws i think they're
one of those heinous things let's hit
these super chats my friends if you
haven't already smash
that like button and comment get your
super chats in go to timcast.com become
a member
if you click that big blue members only
button you can sign up i have good news
too i think we're really close to
launching
new stripe integration which means
alternate forms of payment and uh we've
we
have got a bunch of amazing updates
coming soon we're hiring a bunch of
people but it takes a long time but i
think we're really close to getting like
the news division set up and everything
so we're gonna have articles on the site
we're gonna be completely redoing the
site once again because it's a process
of just building it up as we go
so uh stay tuned for that we will have a
bonus segment coming up around 11 pm
tonight
let's read super chats all right so i
can't read i can never read the first
name of the first super chat apologies
but they said
tim and team is awesome i look forward
to your videos every day
real quick yesterday the site got funky
aired out trying to access members only
it's because we've got a team of amazing
and smart people
trying to work out bugs and stuff um let
me just say
we the website's growing faster than we
expected and so it's kind of a good
problem to have success problem
unfortunately it's inconvenient for you
guys you know normally like companies
will be like okay we're gonna start a
website we're gonna build it up for me
it was like
we just got a very really simple
wordpress design and then it took off so
quick we were like our server can't
handle this
our web hosting can't you know our video
hosting can't handle this so we're
rapidly
trying to upgrade and we were like one
step behind every step of the way not
realizing
how quickly things were growing and then
it was like a couple months and i'm like
we're gonna start doing movies and tv
shows cause like
the growth is massive so you guys rock i
really appreciate it and i apologize for
the errors and the bugs but um
we're doing everything we can to get
through them and make it easier for
people to sign up
or if you want to cancel we just need to
get to these points
new integration for members and
you know look i gotta be honest most i
think it's it's like three to four
months to build a basic website and we
put ours up like really quickly not
thinking all that much about it and then
it just grew too quickly so now
the site is live with members and we're
trying to update everything in real time
so
appreciate it bear with us all right
trip sucks says trivia
which anime is the best anime of all
time and why is it shrek
because shrek has smash mouth in their
soundtrack
uh the best anime i prefer dragon ball z
i'm just a fan
i i i think it's fair to say that in
terms of like gross revenue and
popularity dragon ball z
i think from objective standpoint would
be considered the greatest of all time
just because of
how it kind of went mainstream i mean it
still it still exists they had a
real person movie it was terrible yeah
that was awful but i think it was like
i think dragon ball z is the most
successful but i don't know maybe
um the first half of death note i don't
want to spoil death note
it's good amazing full metal alchemist
both iterations you know
and cowboy bebop it got cancelled
because it was too brutal it's a lot of
really good anime cowboy bebop is
incredible
p diesel says tim you're an idiot build
an airsoft range
if you build it luke will come oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah they're right oh airsoft
yeah we got a bunch of airsoft good old
days let's do it
all right let's find some super chats
zuwa uh bro says tim you have to know
that a lot of us cops view this job as a
calling
we want to go after criminals and help
others lots of cops are going to other
agencies states that offer more support
i like cops i've had bad experience with
cops most interactions most people have
with cops negative why
cops gonna give you a ticket tell you
you can't do that not to pastor you or
bother you but because
cops give tickets some people have bad
experiences i've had some good
experiences
but uh i like cops um what i don't like
is the horribly run corrupt political
states in democrat-run cities
and blue states and the cops who are
allowing that to keep happening
so i think the good cops in these areas
who view it as a calling i mean
find a red state make a decision start
making some phone calls find a
department sheriff's department local
department
and go work for a real department where
let me tell you guys a story
in the in in in i was in virginia a long
time ago
and i know this guy and he was he was
really young he's like 18.
and i guess he opened a car door and
bumped the other car
and then panicked and then drove off
that's a hit and run
so when the cops showed up to our
apartment to my friend's apartment
they were worried they freak freaking
out oh man
hit a car dented it the cops young guys
were like look dude
you shouldn't have done it we just need
your insurance information nobody's
getting in trouble
we understand you kind of freaked out
and he was like okay and then as they're
filling it out the other cops like
family guys on starts making jokes and
we're all laughing having a good time
those are good cops they didn't need to
put a kid in prison for
bumping someone's car with a door or
something they just said just give us
the insurance information and everyone's
happy
that's the way it's supposed to be
instead you go to cities like chicago
i had a cop pulled me over in chicago i
wasn't speeding and he walks up and he's
like you were speeding and i was like um
sorry i wasn't i was actually exiting
off onto belmont from lake shore drive i
was actually slowing down
wasn't speeding and he goes tell it to a
judge sign here that's it
and i'm like so i can't afford this i
was making 10 bucks an hour i can't
afford a 75
ticket doesn't matter they didn't care
they just don't care about you
so i'm like you don't want to live in
these cities where the cops just don't
care about you go
live go to these smaller areas as rural
areas happen to be more red
and then you you can actually go to your
local department meet the cops shake
their hand
tell them where you live let them know
what's up and you'll have good
conversation
that's what i think it's all about
cities are just
zelez says tim love the show ian and
lids are great today is my birthday so i
hope you'll excuse my shout out for my
new watch company ivi
watches hey happy birthday
justin bookman says what which episode
of futurama do you think we're in tim
the one about mother's day robo takeover
or the one with senator travers
ian tell me how you get him to to stare
you with such
passive aggression when you mention the
federal reserve
hello lydia because he knows i'm right
the federal reserve
uh i don't there's no passive aggression
i think it's funny when he embraces the
federal reserve i like that it's
it's me yeah it's like a meme yeah
trending on twitter oh
but but you you know what was it where
uh where the teacher
what movie was it where he would like
shake his fist and yell about the the
nerds or whatever
i can't remember but you need to go
federal reserve
the meme of ron paul disguising the
federal reserve as a home depot hoping
that
like a nike store yeah so good
yeah love it eric miller says the feds
seized a 1 000 safe deposit
seized 1000 safe deposit safe deposit
boxes
with one warrant in california source is
la times article
we've been complaining about the second
amendment here's an infringement to the
fourth
whoa wow wow
big mac attack says hey tim and gang up
here in canada they've started to
mobilize the troops
and set up covet checkpoints on top of
all of that here in alberta
we just had our premier think state
governor announce that if you don't pay
your coveted tickets you won't be able
to renew your registration
wow wow canada's wild yeah canada has a
horrible place
canada is just a mess even worse in the
u.s
big league drew says tim i disagree with
you 50 of the time
but i appreciate what you do even if it
even if i disagree liberty or
death let's go i would rather die on my
feet than live on my knees cheers
i'm a gorilla and i'm just going to read
that part but it's a good name but i'm
not i can't read the rest
drew is on fire fire fire fire keep up
the good work
tim and crew thank you man yeah you were
just there at the border
i think we we mentioned that i don't
know if that was hammered home you were
there for four days
yeah yeah let's see our brace well says
thank you drew your opening rant is 100
correct and your anger is 100 justified
let's stand together and fight back
harder you know i want to share
something real quick
um just for people that are that are
listening and
you know you're just this alt-right uh
person of color that's trait
uh a traitor to your race this is all i
ever hear right
you just want to appease the white man i
i
i have experienced okay my family has
experienced
racism okay when i was a little kid
we had a white supremacist ex-cop okay
to to even top the story
um that lived right next to us on a
daily basis
he would go outside when my mom was
watering the garden and he
you know she was taking care of things
outside she was pregnant with
my little brother on a daily basis he
would threaten to kill my dog he would
call my mom
a mexican pig he would call her
disgusting all these racial slurs on a
daily basis
to the point where he physically
assaulted my little sister in the front
yard
and it also took a high-powered hose
sprayed her straight in the face when
she was like
two two years old it blew her back she
fell on the back of the pavement
um so i'm someone that has i i've
experienced this stuff okay like
i know what it's like to live next to a
white supremacist
ex-cop okay but here's where i defer
uh from the left and i think this is why
they don't like me
differ from differ this is why i defer
from the left
i i will never be a victim okay i i will
never
sit there and and allow myself to become
a victim
even to a white supremacist even to an
ex-cop that abused
his power we're supposed to trust these
people in society okay
i will never allow myself to be put in a
position
where i will forever be a victim under
somebody who hates me because of the
color of my skin
i will never put myself i will never
subject myself
under the authority of someone that
looks down upon me
because of the color of my skin listen
even though some bad things have
happened to me in my family
i refuse to live my life
under someone who is literally
under the assumption that they are
supreme over me
because of the color of their skin this
is where i defer
from other minorities listen they may
not they may want to play a victim
i don't because i think we let them win
and
at least i've told this story so many
times and there's even people that you
know you're just full of crap that's not
true i'm like dude
yeah that's my this is some serious
stuff that happened to me in my family
but i don't turn around and blame all
white people i don't turn around and
blame all cops i don't turn around and
play this little victim
where you should give me everything
because i've experienced this
yes justice was served yes they didn't
the cops didn't even believe my mom
they didn't believe my mom they thought
she was lying okay so i've experienced
injustice in the context of white
supremacy from an ex-police officer
but i will not play a victim because i
believe
that that puts me in a position where
that person will always be
on top of me and always be the little
brown kid that's on the bottom
i will not let them win we cannot let
them win even when it's real
we have to assert ourselves and be
dominant and not
play victims even when it is a real
situation
so this i gotta say this tim i always
get this
you've never experienced you don't know
what it is you don't know what it's like
to live like this
you don't know what it's like to
experience white supremacy i'm like yeah
actually i do
because my family experienced it the
difference between me and you is i'm not
playing this little victim and letting
them win
that's what they want to do to maintain
their narrative i just wanted to share
that i've never shared that publicly by
the way all right
all right tranex says what do you guys
think about making an online country
it would be founded on a bill of
internet rights it would collect taxes
that would guarantee its citizens
internet access and a legal defense fund
and instead of a social security number
you'd have a blockchain number
it's like a membership service sure yeah
check out the manila principles
towards an internet constitution
dustin schimmel says tim bring more
people with this guy's passion please
we get a lot of people who are like oh
tim thanks for
having me i keep having to turn their
mic up not through last the mic
all the way to max no it's really turn
it down you're like oh jesus people
limited people who watch my show they
know this is all you get you are on the
border man
was that just like agitate or were you
just like building aggression agitation
as you were there
i mean man i i'm i'm very passionate
like i am a preacher man but at the same
time it's like
like i was explaining at the beginning
of the show is these people
they dictate who you are they tell you
you're too poor they tell you you're
you're too uneducated they they tell you
that oh we need to take care of the
migrants we care so much about them and
you go down to the border and it's like
no no they don't especially when joe
biden incited this
calling for a surge at the border you
guys caused this
so don't sit there and tell me that you
care about latinos and hispanics when
you're putting latinos and hispanics
coming from central america
in positions to be raped murdered and
kidnapped this is why
listen that's why i said at the
beginning of the show you guys are going
to hear me say some crazy stuff
this is not left this is not right this
isn't me being a conservative or
sympathizing with republican talking
points no th these are serious issues
that you should care about that are
taking place in your own backyard
in your own country all right we got
this from malta leonis
gonna drop a hard one for drew and we'll
definitely follow your content
i believe too many people are willing to
think too little of others without
critically thinking
and come to absurd conclusions without
realizing it
gordy police says as sargon once said
white supremacist with a guilty
conscience
that's absolutely correct yep
all right we got too many super chats
thank you guys
ossary says supporting blm is like
parachute pants in the 80s or mc hammer
pants in the 90s except it's racist
ideology and can't wait until it passes
it is a fad floorbow adjacent says hero
7 is pronounced like cairo
cairo 7. it physically hurts to hear
pronunciation
good i'm glad i'm glad you hate my
pronunciation
and i i briefly lived in seattle too so
you think i know that right
apparently not andrew bishop says drew
fully agree with what you're saying
tim problem with police leaving is what
raises uh raises in the power vacuum
maybe like people being responsible for
themselves
and appreciating the second amendment
for what it's supposed to do
when people say it's about fighting
tyrannical government and the left says
it's about a government-controlled
militia
it's about technically neither it's well
i mean it's about fighting government i
guess toronto government
it's literally just the security of a
free state that means
criminals attacking your property if
criminals can run through the country
and destroy everything you don't got a
free state
if foreign invaders can come in you
can't defend yourself no free state
if a radical government arises no free
state it's about everything it's just
literally
people need to have guns that's the
founding fathers were sitting there and
they're like
yo people should have guns and they're
like that's a good idea write it down
that's it yeah it's not complicated and
then they opined on it later on more in
detail but they literally just write
y'all can have guns
yes but i love how there's an argument
from the left that keeping and bearing
arms doesn't mean you can bear them
outside your house
i guess we'll just have to buy up all of
the houses oh yeah like so you buy like
like two city blocks and then you're
walking down
all the lawns carrying a gun and the
cops like what are you doing
it's okay i own all of these homes i
bought them all so i could walk around
the neighborhood with my gun that's
right
you buy like all of one side of one
block so you can walk all the way around
with your weapon to the grocery store
yeah even though they call planet earth
are home there you go
oh there you go good point i like that
[Laughter]
wayne homan says banning a flavor of
cigarettes for zero reason
they've made me wake up and choose maybe
non-civil disobedience no no we've got
to be
uh peaceful persuasive and resourceful
yeah we talked about this the other day
with with jack murphy
the left gets away with riots and
violence because they control the
cultural institutions and because the
police are willing to
enforce both sides while the da's are
only willing to charge one side
for the most part so that means when
you're on
when you're an enemy territory and
you're like la resistance imagine if
in in in nazi occupied france the french
resistance
all came out of their homes and marched
towards the nazis like we're gonna go to
battle like a regular army
they'd just be like gone so they were
subversive
they had to find different ways to to
fight back now
we're in fourth and fifth generation
warfare which means you've got to be
peaceful you have to be
because you lose the moment the media
can scare
uninitiated individuals into begging for
for authority right january you get you
get one january 6
and then all of the the people in the
cities who don't pay attention are
cowering and hiding
as brian stelter goes the sixth the sex
meanwhile when the building's burning
down a few blocks away they don't hear
about it
so you got to be peaceful has to be done
that way
maniac venture says i'm done with jimmy
dore his hatred for us and cops really
is toxic
he can't seem to call out the ccp
without pointing fingers at us
while he smirks well jimmy is a leftist
but i i think jimmy's allowed to have
opinions we don't agree with my thing is
that jimmy's honest
and i'm totally cool with people who are
leftist so long as they're honest and
they engage in actual conversation
i will also shout out destiny do you
guys hear destiny got banned from twitch
yeah again no this is this is this is
total bs
you know we we we had destiny on the
show of course we argued we agree on
some things we mostly disagree i think
but he absolutely should be allowed to
to you know
have his show and speak what happened
was he had a guest who was
in like a webcam and she held up a
picture of hunter biden
from one of these you know like women on
him twitch bands that stuff apparently
and so they banned that that was that
that's messed up
like going on destiny's show and then
holding up a picture of something taboo
ah man that was that was that was messed
up but twitch i gotta say this
destiny man you reap what you sow
i don't think you should be banned you
should be restored but i gotta say you
know destiny was on the show talking
about how he was in favor of critical
race theory and social justice
okay well that's why you get banned
because amazon adheres to those rules
and caters to those people
i don't know what to tell you man other
than i think that shouldn't be that way
and of course i'll always stand up
against that
all right let's see where we're at uh-oh
oscar j says here pim tool you cried
about the cop getting donated money
secretly because you want us to donate
to you instead yeah
lol no um i don't care you donate too
tony baloney says i use i used to be
abolished the police i changed
realizing this is what the left wants
they will be replaced by henchmen who
have sworn no oath to protect
to protect the constitution communism
take over i'm i'm sorry i
i just can't believe that if the cops
swore an oath to uphold the constitution
they wouldn't be arresting people for
having guns
period end of story so uh yeah i don't
think that cops are upholding their oath
to the constitution i really really
don't that doesn't mean i think police
should be abolished for that reason
i think at this point everyone's voted
i hear these people in the media no
one's really saying abolish the police
no no a new york times op-ed said yes we
mean abolish the police
i didn't hear y'all pro police liberals
come out and defend them
okay so we've got 20 votes for
abolishing
80 votes abstaining abolish the police
wins
next motion you know when i was in
minneapolis
one of the uh speakers with black lives
matter
he was playing a lot of like old school
black panther
um and not the marvel movie black
panther like speeches and music and
chants and all this stuff and
one of the comments like it's it's clear
one of the comments he made was
yes we will abolish the police someday
so we can control them if people don't
believe me you can check my twitter
right now drew h live it's literally on
there this is what they are
saying and preaching it's not just
abolish get rid of them
they want to reinstall they want to
control they want to
that's but that's what look at the cops
in new york who lined up outside of a
bar
yeah and arrested the guy because he was
giving food away yeah that you think i'm
going to control those guys
no i'm not i'm not saying i'm defending
now i'm just saying i'm not saying you
i'm saying
they're rhetorically like these people
think i'm gonna defend these cops you
think
when you're like there'll be a power
vacuum tim and the and and the corrupt
will get their police force they already
have it
they already have it sorry i think you
got to defend
socialized police policing in general
but not the individual corrupt
dudes i think the left is making a
really great case for private police
you know because i've often said i don't
like the idea of private cops because
i'll hire you know uh policies junior
you'll hire
you know like long john polices and
ian's got old country police
and then what happens when we all call
our private police and they're like
staring at each other
yeah like what happens but i'll tell you
now the problem is if you've got a
monopolized police through socialization
then someone need only get elected and
they can wield the entire power of every
police department and guess whoever they
want
nah you know i i used to think that cops
would stand up and be like hey i'm not
playing that game
but most cops don't know and don't care
there's gonna be like i gotta go arrest
this guy
so and i'm talking about big cities bear
in mind sheriff's departments and local
cops
i've had nothing but good experiences
with with you know when we were up in
the philia in the suburbs the cops there
were amazing
i'd go in there and they were very
helpful very nice would hang out like
you know i'd go in for something and
we'd talk i was getting my firearms
federal my firearms license or whatever
and the cops they were super cool helped
me out
called them for help they were very calm
and they took care of everything
didn't brutally brutalize anybody or
beat anybody you know that ever happened
but you live in a big city run by
democrats and you get
i guess bad cops
james de gris says don't be sad when you
get jury duty
get on that jury and use jury
nullification yes
bob cartwright says fun fact in new york
state if you put self-defense as a
reason for application for a concealed
carry permit
your application is denied because the
implied desire to shoot someone
huh yep that's hilarious
dylan says legality does not equal
morality correct
that's right yep eric a says abolish the
fbi there is no function they provide
that is not redundant
aside from their centralized databases
and labs upgrade the state's
capabilities and abolish the fbi
interesting i i kind of feel like we're
heading towards
divorce you know people like michael
mouse had peaceful divorce
the state's breakup or whatever to
prevent you know civil war
i think it's gonna happen no matter what
they're gonna they're gonna rip apart
the police departments people are gonna
get fed up
the sooner the police quit the quit the
the faster people will realize they're
going to be responsible for themselves
people already have no confidence in joe
biden they're not watching him speak
their thumbs downing him on youtube
people don't have faith in the system
anymore it's it's falling apart
very true crazy aquarium says please
respond to my pitch email i sent
yesterday
my email has something to do with the
word faison yay or nay respond anyway
i am more than willing to work with you
as hard as i can to make this
collaboration work
you want to generate culture you got it
we will check into that
faison
senior senor hones says
holy hell tim painting all cops with a
broad brush is beyond insane
ein or any officer i've ever worked with
did any of the things
any of those things absolutely
despicable how about you actually talk
to an officer instead of spouting
nonsense
well we would love to get an officer on
the show we had one we had one yeah we
had brandon we had brandon
he was a former officer yeah former
officer and he made a lot of really good
and important points
but uh i'm not a big fan of big city big
city police departments i've had
a really bad experience i would like to
get a police chief like even a big city
police chief and a beat cop
together on the show that don't know
each other right
that'd be interesting different
different jurisdictions yeah alexander
ferris as i agree with tim
it's ridiculous the cops that arrest
law-abiding citizens
in the cops that arrest law-abiding
citizens in prison or putting them in
prison are truly evil
the cops that do that should be in
prison eric d says shouldn't the old
lady move to a rural area with 200
in her pocket because that's what
chicago voted for yes
exactly now my point is if someone lives
in an area that you know they're 65 so
maybe they moved there when they were in
their 20s
and it wasn't that bad and over time it
got really bad and now they're starting
to realize just how bad it is
and they say i better protect myself so
before they move out
maybe the old lady's going to the atm to
get the 200 to leave
there's a scenario it's a little old
lady who says things have gotten too bad
i'm getting out of here
but i better have a weapon because i got
to get my last bit of cash out of the
atm to pay for gas
and then a cop shows up and he laughs
ma'am what you did was illegal i'm gonna
have to put you in prison for four years
i know a dude who was driving through
illinois from california to
to the east coast he had guns with him
they stopped they pulled him over in
illinois he got arrested went to prison
and then when he got out he was on
probation so he couldn't leave the state
now i'm like so they forced you to be a
resident of illinois
all right he had like licenses for all
his guns and they did that licenses for
all his guns
how's that work was you don't get a
license for guns registration
they were all registered and everything
what do you mean registered like his
weapons that need regi to be registered
weapons like nfa items like machine like
like
full auto handguns whatever you'll
register that what are you talking about
i don't know much about guns
yeah you depend depending on which state
you're in you walk in you felt the
background check form they had you the
gun
but everything was legit and they still
busted them forward
so imagine being from the west coast
well and driving across the country to
move and getting stopped in a state
where the cops say it doesn't matter
what you're doing you're going to prison
and you're like but i don't live here
i'm just passing through but they don't
care
they don't know that for sure if he's
lying they don't care you're supposed to
you got a california plate on your car
and they pull you over you got a
california id and they
put the guy in prison anyway it's the
stupidest thing i've ever heard and it's
like
now he's forced to live there that's
horrible and i was like what is like
it's like this like five years ago i was
like how long do you go to prison for a
couple years
jeez yeah because illinois is insanely
strict
you're supposed to ship the weapons to
like no you have a federal protection if
you're if you're traveling
you're supposed to be protected but the
states often don't care
especially the cops in these areas who
are like and these were even like these
were state cops i think because he was
driving through i guess what happens is
when you're on the federal highway
they can't really do anything they still
might you get off to get gas
yeah so look now the guy lives in
chicago oh my god
and that was funny he's like i made a
life here i have no choice i just think
police officers they need to make some
serious decisions because i you know
when i was reporting
i think it was in louisville last year
um i got arrested for the first time
reporting and uh when that happened
uh they issued a curfew right and all
the conservatives came out and were like
well they issued a curfew drew you
should be following law
so when i got arrested they issued a
curfew and i was still covering the riot
on the ground
uh and the police just kettled everybody
right and i got caught up in that
so you know i'm sitting on the ground i
have antifa and blm
all around me if these people find out
who i am it's not going to be a good
situation so the cop comes up and i'm
like
you know this is who i am you could
check my id you could literally google
me you can call my boss i work for a
former police officer you probably know
who he is
he knew who he was they still arrested
me they still booked me they put me in a
cell of more than like
40 other uh people that were antifa and
black lives matter had to like hide
my identity and everything but what
really pissed me off about
that situation and this is why i always
tell people man i don't support
crooked cops or cops that are bad cops
and that don't uphold their
constitutional oaths i support good cops
uh a lot of conservatives on twitter
were like oh well there was a curfew
drew
why didn't you listen to the cops and
just go back to your hotel i was like oh
yeah you want to know what happened that
night
when i was arrested on the floor the
police officers called the media over
and they called the media over the local
media there was about
20 of them right there filming my arrest
and i was like yeah i understand why
people get pissed especially when i'm
telling the police officer who
you could literally google me right now
doesn't listen to me
so but this is why i i will never
generalize an entire department or all
police officers but i do
i do just want to like say to police
officers man like
it's stuff like that that is not giving
you a good reputation
okay and i don't say that to demonize
all cops
i just say that because i'll always
stand on my position
that i do not support police officers
that do not
uphold their constitutional oaths to
serve and protect the people
i will never i only support those that
do so
i get it i get it absolutely we got call
me straws he says this is how
other totalitarian states create state
law enforcement brown shirts kama rouge
the red guard
the goal isn't police removal it's
replacement by the way
ian would have been a complicit tool of
the state in 40s russia
soldier is rolling in his grave there
you go
i'm interested to hear why you think
that we've got to read soldiers because
there have been numerous instances on
the show where i've actually
asked you moral questions and you defer
to the law yeah right we're on a tv show
what you want to get down and dirty
let's do it when the cameras are off
come on dude we've had quite we've had
conversations about the banality of evil
and you've often sided with
like not not getting your own neck you
know not getting yourself dirty and just
letting the system do what it wants
i mean it's not the first time i've said
that's the banality of evil in response
to your answers to moral questions
this might take a while to talk about i
don't know if right now is the time all
right
all right we'll just do a couple more
because uh we're getting we're a little
bit over time but it's all right it's
always cool
will beasley says thank you for the
brian stelter impression
he's a fake news gremlin fed after
midnight
and you know what happens to gizmo when
you feed him after midnight
he becomes striped you can't get him wet
right right
duplicate don't get him wet
all right let's do a couple more let's
see woodworker anon says hey tim request
for people who don't want to stay on
youtube
can you start live streaming on your
website that would be best thanks for
all you do
one of the things we want to do is like
um set up probably
a streaming we just stream everywhere on
all platforms so just it would go every
website youtube facebook whatever but uh
we're uh we're gonna we'll figure it out
ideally we're gonna have our own website
which we do but like build it up to the
point where it functions like
uh like netflix with a whole roster of
shows and
it's not going to be just you know
political commentary i don't want to do
that
so we'll have the existing shows the
latest show we started is cast castle
which is a vlog
which is not particularly it's not at
all political it's like
what did we do last week we jumped over
the tesla with the bmx well mike feedy
did
so i don't know what we're going to do
this week maybe we have a metal detector
we'll go exploring for civil war
treasure
harper's ferry or something yeah that'll
be fun and we'll film it
do some skateboard whirly birds and
something like that one of the things i
want to do is i want to build an
extremely
long pvc rail because you can bend it oh
and then we can have it like curl around
and go down the driveway which is like
three city blocks long well maybe that's
a little exaggeration it's like a block
lung
but then you can have a rail where you
can like grind down the whole driveway
all to the bottom
nice that'd be fun it's like action park
stuff have you ever seen that
action part action park documentaries
that hardcore like theme park
pretty much do whatever you want you
guys check it out it's on hbo it's
pretty crazy
i wish all right all right you're gonna
like this last one last super chat
andrew bishop says who is this guy and
how can i dump my life savings into his
mission
uh you guys could support me uh at
drewhlive.com
uh the support tab is on there also you
can follow me on twitter
drew h live on gab as well drew h live
instagram drew hernandez live and i have
my nightly youtube
show uh an hour before tim's tomorrow i
made sure that i did that okay
so you can watch drew and then go
straight into tim pool i do it monday
through friday on youtube
uh at 4pm pacific standard time that's 7
p.m eastern standard time so just search
drew hernandez live on youtube
and you can follow me at tim cast but
also more importantly you can follow at
timcast irl
on instagram and facebook and if you're
on facebook and you're following at
go to facebook.comtimcast.irl you can
share
each and every one of the clips from the
show to help help us promote that show
because what we want to do is
you know we build a big enough presence
on facebook but we're going to be
driving people to the website
get more content to people off of
facebook but you know it is what it is
so uh don't forget to check out my other
youtube channels youtube.comcast and
youtube.comcastnews we're live on this
show monday friday at 8pm and now you
must go over to timcast.com to become a
member
because we're gonna have an exclusive
members only segment this is where we
get rowdy
because on the website we're allowed to
basically we're effectively allowed to
say whatever we want
and that means like swearing for the
most part and having the conversations
youtube doesn't like
so go check that out and uh thanks for
hanging out ian do you want to yeah you
can follow me at ian crossland and at
ian crossland.net if you want to get in
touch with me there through check out
all my socials i really appreciate you
guys coming
and listening to this hard hard
conversation this is not an easy
conversation this is a hard time uh
i think the conversation we are the
strong people for this hard time i dare
say and i would
i think that uh the lesson we can take
from ian and the homework i'm going to
give you all for tomorrow
is to really think about your
understanding of evil think about what
makes something actually correct and
good and what makes something evil and
wrong
and i am sour patch lids you can follow
me on twitter help me in my pursuit
of that let's see i want to have more
followers and sour patch kids on twitter
we will see you all over at timcast.com
in the exclusive members only segment
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you